the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the gloves have come off at the U.S
women's and U.S open championships in St
Louis with title chances on the line
underdogs need to land a knockout blow
if they hope to stand a puncher's chance
Fabiano caruana has the eye of the tiger
dodging Jabs and Landing Haymakers to
hold a clear lead in the open Jennifer
you just keeps swinging fighting till
the final Bell Rings to remain at the
top of the standings Challengers are
within Striking Distance will they
become contenders or go down for the
count day 11 of Lights Out chess coming
up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everybody to day 11 of the
2022 US championships and U.S women's
chess Championships held at the St Louis
chess club we start the day in front of
the beautiful Forest Park as we are
waiting for the players to arrive while
with only three rounds to go who is
going to make the best chess moves and
come out on top let's go to the studio
and find out with Yasser and Anastasia
from the home of Chess in the United
States welcome to the Saint Louis chess
club and the 11th round of the USGS
championships in the U.S women's chess
championships
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Anastasia carluge and
I'm here joined by my brilliant co-host
Grandmaster and fourth time US champion
Yasser ceremon awesome Anastasia
beautiful to be with you in studio yes
we had a great day yesterday because it
was free day and the weather was great
and we had a great walk everyone I'm
sure about that yeah sir how was it it
was all good it was all good and it felt
like it went by and a third of the time
that it does when you're actually
working hello everyone and Welcome to
our show after a much needed rest day
the fans the players the commentators
even the podcasters are ready for the
final Sprint who will have the best kick
in these final three rounds Anastasia
please do the honors and tell us about
our leaders in starting with the ladies
so let's check the leaders we have
Jennifer Yu who has seven out of 10
points and she is in the soul leave now
Irina Crush follows her step only how
Point behind for six and a half pounds
and then we have a big group of people
chasing them begging client to the third
position together with Alice Lee Thalia
Cervantes Megan Lee all of them they
have six points outstanding and in the
open section what about our leader born
there and we have Fabiano caruana with
seven points and the first place Ray
Robson only like one step behind him six
and a half points and then we have a
group of people who chase them one point
behind linear Dominguez Jeffery drunk
Sam shell Glenn direswear sam7 as well
as a Wonderland all of them are hoping
to climb even you know and came back to
the fight for the first position exactly
really a tight pack there and our format
for these national championships in
nature went with her 14th players it's
round robin event everybody will have 90
minutes for the first 40 moves then 30
minutes for the rest of the game 30
seconds increment from move one and of
course not everyone body fights until
that we have no Rovers in this
tournament and tell me about the
remaining schedule
and we have one list three rounds left
included around today and if needed
we'll have playoffs on October 20s as
well as the closing ceremony
some details on the closing ceremony
Anastasia the closing ceremony will take
place on 20th of October it starts at 7
6 PM with cocktails yes and then we have
the working ceremony itself and after
party so everybody who would like to
come and see the players and have some
cocktails and join the after party
you'll just buy the ticket for 25
dollars and then you are here and in
case if you cannot be here you can watch
it online yes and streaming very very
very nice very nice and we're lucky to
have in studio with Christian and he
you're gonna drill down on our leaders
tell us tell us about their road ahead
Christian good to see you my friend good
to see you guys great uh to be back in
the studio we are all re-energized and
ready to rumble here at the US chess
championships and let's take a look at
where our leaders stand as we enter the
final stages we're going to start with
the open section and one Ray Ross who is
only half a point behind the leader of
Fabiano caruana right now he started off
with five draws in the first five games
but after that a huge hat trick in round
six seven and eight allowed him to get
very closely behind only half a point
behind Fabiano caruana and what is his
road ahead looking like for the next
three rounds well today I have to say a
big opportunity against a Wonder Liang
whose openings I have to say have been
quite shaky and he has white in that
game Ray Robson that is in round 12 a
big Clash against Christopher you with
the black pieces but we know Ray can win
with the black pieces as well and in the
final round with the white pieces
against Jeffrey Sean only half a point
behind one Fabiano caruana and let's
take a look at how our leader got to
where he is today well a very steady
event for Fabiano caruana started off
with two draws and after that he started
winning right now he is on plus four
half a point ahead of Ray Robson and one
and a half Point ahead of every body
else and let's take a look at his road
ahead as we enter the last three well
today a big opportunity with the white
pieces and it's all about who has those
white pieces in the last final stages of
the tournament and today a big chance
against Jeffrey Sean a difficult matchup
with the black pieces against the 2018
us chess champion Sam Shanklin and in
the final round against his good friend
Levon aronian also with the white pieces
and let's take a look at where our
ladies stand as well this is our leader
woman Grandmaster Jennifer Yuan she's
been tied or in Seoul first position for
7 out of 10 Rounds that's just simply
incredible she is accustomed to being
the leader of this event but there is
also chasing closely behind One a-time
National Champion Grandmaster Irina
crush he's been tied or sold first three
out of over 10 Rounds guys we're going
to have some incredible matchups
especially in tomorrow's round take a
look at this oh my wow what a big game
this will be between Jennifer you with
the white pieces against Irina crashing
as we can see Irina never managed to
take down Jennifer but well she might
need to do that in round 12 tomorrow but
still mouth-watering games all around in
round 11 and we're just about to start
absolutely thanks for that Christian as
we see Chris bird the Arbiter there
wanding the players as they come in
Anderson your turn yes let's make sure
no electronic devices all part of our
fair play rules uh uh uh uh she had
something in her pocket what was that
with that she has actually Ukrainian
flag on her floor really yes lucky
and uh Anastasia please do the honors
tell us about the pairings for this
round 11 in the ladies so if you just
look up you will see Jennifer you
playing together
wow what a marquee matchup exactly a big
implant to the third position it's
really important for her to try to win
and then if you go come down the table
you will see Arena Crush do they playing
against tomorrow yes very very important
yeah yeah it says tap Tiff as well and
uh key key pairings in round 11 for the
opening so we have Fabiano carono facing
Jeffrey Jones Christian just said right
as well as Ray Robson playing against
the Wonderland these are our two first
places and then we have nice matches
also between Samsung
linear Dominguez will play against
Christopher you and also
um interesting match between wuhan's
Neiman and Alexander Alex Slenderman the
players have all been fighting hard hard
and then for the ladies what price
funder they've been fighting for
oops and here it is and we have 160 500
price fund the champion of us women's
gym a championship will take 40 000 then
we have 30 and 20 uh Southern all the
way until 14th Place was three thousand
very very generous indeed and in the
open section what are they fighting for
262
000 price fund and sixty thousand will
be for the first uh place and then the
silver medalist will get 45 and then 35
all the way until 5500. wow when I was
winning a U.S Championship six thousand
was first 5500 is lasted this one thank
you St Louis safe so thank you St Louis
chess club as you hear the bell sound a
few of players likely still stuck in the
line getting more wanted and there you
see Jennifer you our current tournament
leader waiting for her opponent
Christian unfortably reminded as we as
we start our Sprint these last three
rounds that in the U.S Championship that
Sam
Shanklin won he was tied with Fabi with
three games to go Fabi scored two and a
half and said it was my first check if I
checked for First Flight
are you predicting a Sprint a big kick
for any of these players oh absolutely
and I think Ray Robson in particular I
think he knows that he needs to score
some victories in the last three rounds
because also Fabiano caruana and they're
actually having very similar
um challenges in terms of their parents
and their colors that they play with so
both have white in today's gaming Ray
Robson is going to try to put some
pressure as well as Fabiano caruana
because he knows he most likely needs to
win at least one of the next three games
to maintain his lead I don't think
Fabiano wants to go to a tie breaks
that's something that he wants to avoid
right now his insole leadership position
he wants to maintain that absolutely I
find it interesting that Fabi opened up
with one D4 in the Americas cup which he
won in their first match Jeffrey Zhang
nearly upset uh Fabi Fabi won the won
the match when Jeffrey overstepped the
time control and Jeffrey was winning in
that game and the funny part is that
Fabiano was actually getting completely
winning positions out of the open that's
what I wanted to say with E4 with E4 one
E4 and Jeffrey was responding with the
French defense always getting pretty
much objectively winning positions with
white including that game that he won
just because Jeffrey flag don't forget
that Jeffrey is my pick so I'm really
curious what is going to happen in this
game maybe I still have some chances
me versus you honestly Christian feels
too comfortable these days let's make it
more interesting very Fabi is his choice
you guys are piling up on me because in
the ladies section is me versus yazareth
I think right right and VAR VAR I have
to congratulate him on his on deep
understanding he joined me yes and the
picks
um look this is an opening circus that
I'm looking at between Alice Lee and
tatav
um I played the Queen's Gambit declined
all my life and it's it's no I never
played the Magnus Carlson approach with
A7 A6 yes I played Bishop E7 yes I
played Knight D7 yes I played Bishop B4
I even played C7 C6 but I never played
Asics and I certainly never played
it's like what like what I don't know
where we are but h7h6 is a
a confusing one for me I must I just I
will just say if it's psychological yes
or maybe Ellis place all the time Bishop
G5 move and then your opponent plays H6
to make sure you will not get your
position definitely not right Europe is
a little bit disappointed yes all these
things okay now what shall I do with
this bishop exactly E3 and close it
forever how interesting I I think when
my opponent makes a move out of turn I
consider the move H7 H6 a poor decision
just leave it there and anytime my
opponent makes such a decision as h7h6 I
start to think well how can I take
advantage of it by transposing it as
something else and in this case this
move G2 G3 attracted my attention I'll
play a Catalan yes
yeah which is maybe not useful so Alice
so showing some remarkable maturity to
choose G2 G3 Bishop D6 came instantly
like yeah I was expecting the Catalan
really yeah it's like what really yes
sir it's really nice what you just
mentioned but you know if you have a
reporter that you can have some choices
it's good but if you're you don't know
some sisters
it's so easy to take advantage of
difficult plays right but there's
something about this position right I
mean why would black put her Bishop on
D6 this is something that we learned
when we're kids whenever we Face uh this
Pawn chain on King side this fiance the
pawn chain H2 G3 supported by F2 as well
you generally want to keep the bishopone
seven right right not develop it all the
way to D6 so this is a bit of a weird
configuration for uhative but she is
blitzing out her moves so she really
must be knowing something in the
position maybe chance to push E5 later
on in the game of course yeah this is
the only explanation yeah something like
takes with 97 and E5 on her agenda if
I'm in Alice's shoes I'm castling and
I'm saying what are you going to do one
of the things that off often black likes
to do is takes I wouldn't advise it
exactly in this moment and the reason
for that is that imagine I play the move
Knight D2
there's no way that you can defend the
pawn on C4 you can't even get into some
of those positions that are kind of
weirdly uh from B5 no I'm just going to
play Knight takes C4 and this Bishop's
diagonal is really really nice and then
I might capture this bishop on D6 after
Knight takes DC4 so we're gonna find out
what tatsav's Bishop is doing on the D6
career rather shortly but
oh and finally uh our second place uh
leader Ray Robson uh just finally coming
through the door uh five minutes late
that's pretty soon I think there's
somebody else being wanted by crispr
right now we cannot really see him okay
exactly somebody is hidden okay
yeah surprise surprise right
right and Jennifer has been waiting for
begum talk about that matchup if you
will oh you've got something else on
your board well that matchup hasn't
started yet
starts we will be talking about it I'm
sure about that but we should be talking
about this game between Fabiano and
Jeffrey because it's quite intriguing
What Jeffrey is doing so of course
Fabiano most likely has surprised
Jeffrey I cannot remember the last time
Fabiano played the move d4 if we think
about the singfield cup uh the last
major event I don't think we've seen any
1D force from Fabiano and even in the
U.S championships I don't think we've
seen a one D4 from Fabiano so he's been
starting with mostly one E4 right for uh
the last at least a couple of months now
he's going on a completely different
direction and immediately Jeffrey starts
thinking early on in the opening and
chooses this Knight to F6 early on which
has been considered especially at the
elite level to be stopped par in general
black starts with the move Bishop to E7
waiting on where white is going to
commit either the bishop on C1 or the
Knight on a G1 right if you want to play
Knight to F3 then you're not going to be
able to get it all the way to E2 as we
will see later on in the game if you go
Bishop to F or well now I can go Knight
to F6 and the bishop is not on G5 like
in the game so you're just waiting with
this move Bishop to E7 if you do play
the move Knight to F6 now I can take
take and now I can commit my Bishop to
what is considered to be the ideal
Square on G5 so Bishop to G5 C6 E3 and
now we get into this position and as you
can see remember committing the Knight
to F3 he didn't have to commit Fabiano
caruana the Knight to F3 so now you have
the extra option and is considered to be
quite a good option to put the Knight on
E2 after that you're most likely going
to go queen queen to C2 either short
Castle or even long Castle in a certain
instances and you will have ideas of
playing this move F3 followed by E4
without the Knight on F3 you can go F3
and expand in the center with E4 this is
considered to be sub-optimal for black
compared to playing the move Bishop to
E7 early on at move three so quite a
surprising approach by Jeffrey but
definitely he needs to have something in
his pocket I'm sure he knows some ideas
that could potentially give Fabiano some
problems
thank you for that Christian I'm just
looking at the game of Sophie versus
Sabina for a moment a very topical Kara
Khan and this whole Queen A5 Shack
business has one idea and that is you
want to play the move Queen A6 as soon
as possible because you want to
encourage a trade of queens and the
whole point of Queen A5 check followed
by Queen A6 is if White Shoes the trade
like I'm not even sure where the queen
should end up well in this particular
case that's the whole point of Queen A5
and queen A6 I stop you from castling in
the game position after Queen A5 check
uh Sabina said I'm not interested in
trading queens and now that white has
gotten in the move castles there's no
reason to play Queen A6 so then the
question is well why did you play Queen
A5 check in the first place you've gotta
I mean your queen is just out there
doing nothing otherwise you can imagine
white starts thinking well I'll play C4
I'll start playing
A3 B4 I'll just gain space and I'll
thank you for having put a couple
questions there Alice Lee versus tatv I
I thought this was again very funny
because of what you had said Christian
which was that after Knight C6 we're
taught that the bishop doesn't belong on
D6 because it's a Target
so I thought Alice's play was pretty
natural to take on C4 go Knight B5 yes
and if I go Bishop B7 go Bishop four and
that's questions and start to ask
questions if you want to put your knight
on E8 you're more than welcome to do
that but then after moves like Knight E5
and or Rook C1 we can see who's going to
get an early initiative with the white
pieces Alice pardon me Alice played a
move that sub-optimal in my in my view
a2a3 it's sort of like a passing move
what this move really says if it's my
turn I will play C5 and immediately
before that's what A3 says so she's
trying to take an advantage of those
moves like 96 Bishop D2 with a different
approach exactly with with A3 now
however after takes if you play E4 and
you kind of go into it and kind of a
Gambit well then E5 live and black setup
has not been punished let's put it that
way yeah and if you go Queen A4 In This
Moment well again I'm thinking that that
the black should get in this freeing
break E5 and somehow tataf is making her
position work we'll we'll keep an eye on
this one quickly going to Megan Lee
who's really been she did great through
about seven rounds yeah she's six out of
eight yeah and then she lost two games
yes exactly she's up against Rue Yang
Yan today let's see if she can write her
ship she still has six points she's on
the outside looking in she needs some
help as well as a strong kick to finish
the tournament Rochelle versus Anna well
once again we see another Queen's Gambit
decline Queen's Gambit declines very
popular in this round 11 and Christian
turning uh it over to you what caught
your eye so I'm looking at this game
between Wesley and elshon because it's
quite interesting how it started Knight
to F3 and now the O'Kelly once again
essayed by elshon we've seen this in his
game against uh I think it was Sam
Shanklin early on in the tournament and
Sam responded with the move G3 well
probably Wesley was ready for it because
he already showed elshon that is that he
is willing to play this move A6 so he
started with C3 D5 and now we have this
position D4 take on D4 and not recapture
immediately with the queen or with the
pawn because then you can recapture with
either the Knight or the queen if you
take with the queen I take back with a
queen and this looks like a very good
position for uh black seems like he
almost equalized out of the opening but
you have this idea intermental check
Queen to A4 now you can play the move
Queen to D7 or Bishop to D7 this seem to
be the main lines in the position after
Bishop to D7 now I can take on D4 and
you no longer have an immediate way to
recapture on D5 this is going to lead to
a much better position just simply upon
up I'm going to be able to defend this
Pawn with the move C4 I don't see the
compensation in Black's position so
Queen to D7 seems to be the main line
but the question is what if I take you
take back let's say with a knight or
with a bishop and then I continue with
C4 I'm not taking on D4 but rather I'm
focused and I'm prioritizing defending
the pawn on D5 and saying hey how are
you Defending Your Own Pawn right on D4
right it seems like right now he's just
simply going to be a pawn down you can
try to create some complications after
the move B5 things of this nature but in
the end it's just going to be me a pawn
up and you trying to find the
compensation which most likely doesn't
exist so I'm seeing Wesley as just
completely better early on in the
opening phase and let's take a look at
what's happening in some other games
Fabiano versus Jeffrey this was most
likely after Castle night D7 is the main
line of course very natural development
you can go 97 Knight f8 then even Knight
to G6 occasionally or Knight to E6
he played the move A5 early on trying to
stop the minority attack for white on
the Queen's side and immediately Rook to
C1 was played by Fabiano which stopped
Jeffrey in his tracks for the moment
Jeffrey had 1 hour and 31 minutes so he
was definitely blitzing out his moves
after the move Rook to C1 he started
thinking now the question is
Rook to C1 doesn't really mesh very well
with the last few moves for white
because once again we were considering
the expansion in the center F3 E4 and
then if you want to go for that in
general this Rook should probably land
on D1 The Rook from A1 should land on D1
because we're going to see uh the needed
Support over the D file to support upon
on D4 after the exchange of the e-pawn
and the d-pawn for white and black so
this one is quite an interesting
approach by Fabiano with a move Rook to
C1 I'm still trying to understand why
my guess is that after this move A5 you
weaken this complex of dark squares
around the queen side so maybe I can try
to take advantage of that with the move
knightway for Knight to C5 things of
that nature and that's why I think
Fabiano wants to have the Rook on C1
this is going to be a very interesting
middle game Brewing uh for well not only
the leadership but maybe even the
championship in the open section
ah thank you Christian for that uh just
like to turn our attention to a player
Lanier Dominguez who has
essentially gone quiet but quite at
least successful as well he has
undefeated which in this field is
incredibly hard to do he is plus one and
he's just in one of those you know he
can reach the podium very very easily
with certain things going his way today
is up against Christopher you and look
at this yeah
4d5 ed5 Queen D5 and I'll tell you a
little secret
about one E2 E4 players well they'll all
profess
that the Scandinavians not that good in
opening and things like that it's
actually a pain for one E2 E4 players
because those E4 players are focused on
the berlins they're focused on the
Petros they're focused on these open
Sicilians so they don't end up paying
too much attention to the Scandinavian
and just a single slip and they get no
Advantage
it's annoying for them now Knight C3 so
the crazy part is the Scandinavian
proper is always featured Queen A5 but
the second one is all guys used to
actually go all the way back to d8 and
say the fact that I've knocked your Pawn
out of the center is worth the tempo and
the modern players are playing this
really really annoying move Queen to D6
and I started to think how the heck am I
supposed to get an advantage as white
against Queen D6 and I'm really
appreciating following the game himself
linear I think he is a fantastic opening
theoretician especially for one E4
players and he's kind of Blazing the way
after G G7 G6 I find
that the Knight on C3 is in the way I
would like the pawn actually to be on C4
or I would like this Knight most
especially to be on E5 like yeah
and I really like I I've never seen I've
never seen this too because I played
this for a while you know so that's why
I remember I used to play some
variations with G3 right Bishop before
trying to take an advantage that Queen
is on D6
or sometimes you kind of there are some
systems you put some night only two and
Bishop before so you're trying to kind
of make this possible and then you find
out that maybe
yes exactly yes your Bishop had F4 maybe
it's not so great so you're winning
Tempe all over the place yes and you
find out that your misplacing your
pieces but this move wow really the
moment I saw it I go
[Music]
let my opponent play a bad move like
Bishop G4 Knight C3 and a moment ago and
I explained how wonderful it would be to
get my well this is a dream come true my
my position is just flowered brilliantly
thanks to the Knight on E4 E5 pardon me
so I looked at this position after
Knight A3 and I find out that there are
Master games yeah it was just that it
was unknown to me you know yeah I also
didn't know this I really like this uh
Knight A3 Christian did was this
something you were aware of because I
was not no of course not no I mean I
don't remember the last time I studied
the Scandinavia there you go you see
back when I was studying the
Scandinavian when I was playing E4
that's more than a decade ago I used to
uh play it with G3 in fact G3 especially
against the queen on DC yes and then try
to get Bishop to F4 Bishop G2 things of
that nature Knight to B5 never was on my
radar right
6 Knight to A3 but it makes sense if you
look at it it makes a lot of sense you
want to play the move C3 solidify the
center as it is and then exactly this
Knight is headed towards E5 most likely
right Knight to C4 with Tempo that comes
with Tempo and then Knight to E5 so if
you look at it from a logical
perspective it makes a lot of sense this
idea of Michael V5 knightway through and
most likely white has a slight Advantage
the typical Advantage out of the opening
when you're playing against the
Scandinavian and when you are playing
this Scandinavian you know you're
probably going to defend a worse
position out of the opening yeah but in
this particular case what I oops sorry
what I mean to say is that the Knight on
C3 is stands in the way of the sea Pawn
Yeah the Knight on E5 is perfect and the
C2 Pawn as you just mentioned going to
C3 and solidifying it's great also we
talk about counter play for black for
just a moment so there are certain
positions where the D4 Pawn faces off
against the E6 Pawn right where the D4
Pawn controls very nice squares E5 and
this E6 Pawn is less
useful so from Black's point of view
black is often times playing for the
moves E5 and C5 as the counter play you
put the pawn on C3 you put the pawn on
Bishop the bishop on G7 and you see that
you're not going to get E5 you may
but I could maybe take advantage of that
by taking and winning Tempe so again I'm
uh thank you Lanier yeah for showing
something new very very nice even though
it's actually been played before making
it uh known I want to say
um Sam Shanklin uh a former US champion
he's like Lanier he's been having a
quiet modestly successful tournament
he's a plus he will be angry about the
fact that he lost one game and one two
but nonetheless it's a plus score he's
white today against Lavon Lavon aronium
and let's just catch up on this game so
it's one of those catalans once again
but again another twist so you can have
an open Catalan with C5 you can have a
closed cattle and it's not really a
cattle and it almost become a slob as
soon as they play B5 so the richness of
the Catalan and I've mentioned it before
in previous broadcasts it it's really
really great how how deep this opening
complex is A4 A6 now Sam
black history very uh I want to say a
great theoretician goes in for a double
Pawn sacrifice check this out takes
takes takes wow wonderful yeah we've got
to give Lavone a membership in the pond
grubbers Association look at this
challenge Water Challenge Queen takes
what are you gonna do well I'm gonna
defend the Rook with a gain of tempo
please go back down the D file so that I
can bring yet more pieces into the
attack
right okay Queen C2 now this move Bishop
A3 has the potential to be awkward
so let's trade Queens exactly and C6 was
hanging as well exactly let's trade
queens and I think we're up to date with
the players after Queen C5 and once
again the opening circus what does the
what does it tell us about the two
double Pawn sacrifice Christian it seems
to be a still Theory exactly at this
point and it's quite clear that Levon is
very much aware of that because he has
one hour and 32 minutes and we actually
don't see Sam very often being down on
time early on in the opening so
definitely this was a surprise by Levon
and he knows it very well he knows
exactly what he's doing now you have a
couple of options maybe even go Queen to
B3 and then offer uh the potential of a
repetition yes right before Queen to C2
Queen to C5 and so on so right now if
you put yourself in Sam shanklin's shoes
you're like okay this guy is blitzing me
out right he obviously knows what he's
doing his two pawns up and maybe I have
the option of repeating the position
rhythm of Queen to B3 am I going to be
oh there we go overly ambitious or not
or try to take the draw and let's see
because Queen to B4 by the way is not
the only move exactly also plays
something like Bishop to E7 critical
moment let's see whether Levon oronian
wants to fight it off and play continue
the game with bishop7 or try to take the
repetition with Queen before that was my
question to you uh Christian besides the
move Queen B3 how would the theory have
suggestions to D3 has been played as
well Queen to D2 and
basically instantly
says yes okay we can do a repetition if
you want Queen C2 C winter C2 so again
now you're saying that after Queen C5
Queen D3 has been played Queen D3 and
queen D2
and uh Queen to B3
and you of those other choices that
don't repeat the position of Queen D3
Queen D2 which one scores the best which
one would the theory say you should go
down this so Queen to D3 seems to be uh
the main line with six games and I think
it's one win no actually is uh
three wins for black is that correct
[Laughter]
with Queen data free so white actually
never won in Queen to D3 at least
according to this database
I do I do I do I do I do very very very
much because I mean even though
sometimes
are different yeah right yes but like
for example when I played my match here
in St Louis against Anatoly carpa
carpathwood in those days was playing
exclusively one D4 okay so then I said
okay when his opponents plays the nimso
Indians what the scar puff scored it was
like 56 karpov is white what about
Queen's Gambit declines 56 what about
the groom fell 70 what about the
um Dutch defense 80 you better than God
that's what I'm saying I mean I got I
got the I got the memo no Dutch defense
wise actually exactly so you prefer
against some of you so that is using
that I discovered that karpov only had
52 against the slav defense okay here we
go it's love defense and if served me
incredibly well for the match now I'm
I'm a little bit thrown off though by
Sam shanklin's choice of the double Pawn
sacrifice though Christian if this
sacrifice works out
the percentage is so good for black why
go down this line as white that is a
very good question I think he just
expected to surprise Levon uh and he
didn't
yes
ready he munched on those pawns with
Incredible speed right putting a lot of
psychological pressure on his opponent
and to be honest right now again if
you're Sam Shanklin I think you take the
draw with Queen B3 right there's no
other practical option because you know
your opponent already knows exactly what
uh to do against the other ideas
just take the draw
I don't understand and accept the fact
that well unfortunately you lost one
white but you didn't lose it against one
of uh the bottom rated players you lost
it against Levon aronium so it's not a
Shameless just take the draw and go home
no but also from the perspective of
Levon I mean he's not playing his best
tournament ever yes he wants this
tournament to be over in a way right all
right you could come to the end somehow
so let's say playing with black pieces
against Sam I think he would should be
satisfied more or less with this result
more or less yes Alex landerman very
very reluctantly accepting a repetition
and just you know being a little bit
frustrated that he had made a poor
choice of opening now we saw a very
frustrated looking Sam Shanklin you
mentioned just a moment ago well you are
threatening the pawn on seasick so which
is one of the reasons why you might play
Queen C5 now after Queen B3
I mean equally black might have just
said Bishop E7 do your worst against
that and I was just wondering yeah
61 right exactly Anastasia and you know
I'm having this horrible uh thought that
well after a move like Bishop D6 great I
won one Pawn back yes but after night
tags and Bishop takes or maybe even I
should take with the Rook you know
is not a big threat anymore right right
because I've defended and I there's only
one reason only two results because
black uh extra Pawn so the more I'm
looking at this Sam can shake his head
all he likes and curses bad luck uh but
I'm seeing a repetition a dead ahead
back over to you uh Chris So
that's fast exactly what happened here
this came between Hans and Linderman
stormed all the way to move 20. wow one
hour and 34 minutes for Alexander 34
minutes for Alexander Linderman and 1
hour and 23 for uh Hans and he was late
to the game also now they obviously both
know the theory right now right and
there's only one move according to a
theory in this position and that is
night to have faith Alexander Linderman
takes on D4 after like a 30 minute 30
second thing and once you take and now
go Knight to f8 Han says sure I didn't
have to lose time with Rook ad1 like in
the main line Knight to f8 and then I go
Rook 81 because you cannot play the move
F3 like it was played in the game if you
play the move F3 here I take excuse me
instead of 4K D1 I take and then I will
defend that with the move E4 that would
be huge you cannot do that so
you have to wait for white to lose one
Tempe with a move Rook 81 and then play
the move takes on D4 and follow uh that
with Knight to E6 but now what we have
in the position take take Knight to f8
and immediately
Han says I'm going to play F3 I'm going
to put some pressure on your Center
that's a disaster not in time
you're not in time yet right so yes if
you go E3 and this is the main idea now
I don't have to go Rook to E1 I have the
extra move of playing wow F4 and the
Knight is not yet on F6 on E6 excuse me
to capture on F4 so that's problematic
for your position F3 puts a lot of
pressure and if you have to take and
allow Rook a F1 I'm going to pick this
guy up but then with the E file open and
my options eventually doubling up on the
e-file where is this Knight going you
cannot put it on E6 anymore Rook D1
finishes the game right
ouch where do you put the Knight how do
you get it back in the game because you
have to land some somehow on C7 and then
on D5 right you're not making it there
in any configuration so right now it
seems like Hans is already much better
after this move F3 and maybe Lenderman
realizes it
we of our repetition Shanklin went for
the repetition
look there's no shame in this yes and as
you can see he's shaking his head he
understands that look I had one extra
day to preparation and this is what I
come up with right at some point you
have to swallow your pride and right
over it that's exactly what he says he's
disappointed because he's a fighter Sam
Shanklin is a fighter and he wanted to
put pressure on the struggling Levon
aronium especially when you have white
pieces with the white pieces exactly
yeah I'd like to turn our attention to
the game between Ray Robson and a
Wonderland because we were all asking
ourselves what would a wonder do today
would he play uh the uh the Petrov
defense with Knight takes E4 uh would he
go into
fabulous
double-edged variation no he just went
straight into into a French defense and
the advanced French defense to my mind
is actually the most dangerous and
strange enough not the Knight C3 not the
Knight D2
stuff that we're all familiar with but
simply E5 and going for the space well a
Wonder said you know Ray I've been
studying your games and in the mainline
variations I like to see what you're
going to do against C5 C4 now when I was
young and
a misspent teenage Hood studying the
games of David bronstein this was a
favorite of David and David did you do
the same now yes sir no
David ruined Generations
Soviet uh chess children with his crazy
and beautiful ideas C5 C4 so well it's
as simple as it looks you give up all
your pressure on the Center White Center
is going to remain intact for a long
long time but what you're going to do is
you're going to nail the square B3
you're going to put a a knight on B3 and
you're going to put your king
on the queen site with the queen side
lockdown Black's King will be safe and
the hope that black has is that he will
use the move F7 F6 to get it whites King
which will be sitting on the king site
great ideas they don't always pan out
let's see what but at least now we know
what the black is doing right exactly
and I have seen how many times have I
seen this trap Knight D2
and black reasons not illogically that
you know it would be really really nice
to have the night on F5 yes so a lot of
black players have blundered the
position away with this very logical
looking move and after Bishop takes E4
yes
like you lose a bone
complete disaster two funds three bonds
and an attack Knight D6 will really ruin
your day but okay I wonder says okay now
as long as this Knight stays on D2 I'm
not jumping to B3 right away but as soon
as this Knight moves away I'm gonna go
Knight B3 okay let's see how the game
continues this is all standard stuff
and one of the wonderful things that
David bronstein would do is he'd get a
position like this and then he would go
night here and let me just make a bad
move just for a moment okay and then he
would go night here okay and Knight
takes and then Bishop here
I want a piece on B3 and then his
opponents would go right here and he
would go night here and he moves that
second night to a fight
I could see you shaking your head
already okay this guy is dangerous right
you just don't follow him David
braunstein marvelous marvelous
theoretician and uh wow okay just we'll
keep an eye Let me refresh my board so I
can get up to date with the players
where are you Ray sorry excuse me for
this moment and here we are what is the
idea of H4 well you're not playing B4
for all of the reasons I just mentioned
including Bishop A4 what you are playing
for is F4 F5 the problem behind an
immediate like approach of let's just be
really cynical about this the problem
with an immediate play for F4 like
something like this yes
is that uh let me make a a move
you hit this F5 yes
yes now you're not really excited about
capturing the pawn on facade and so you
need to be a lot more subtle and that's
where the move H4 comes in so the idea
behind H4 is that we want not that we we
don't want the Knight to sit there
forever we want to go H5 so that when
the Knight goes there we do go change
before so they're just also the prevent
H5 from black side right exactly and
Knight F5 exactly exactly so we could
for example go H5 here and the idea is
after H7 H6 now we often play for F4 and
F5 this way because if black plays F5
the G6 Square falls into whitesmen it's
a very very very subtle uh approach to
the opening and it requires in these
closed positions some really
understanding good maneuvering play it's
not so much about like force play it's
more about the plants and if you know
these ideas or you don't that is why one
E4 players aren't really uh happy about
French defense except Christian
because because the French defense ends
up being maneuvering and it's it's
strategic yes not the tactics uh and
attacking that white players often like
um jump in Christian and tell us what
caught your eye I'm uh switching to the
lady section for just a second and I'm
trying to look at this game between
gurukbang and Jennifer you are a leader
in this one and a big surprise early on
by uh Jennifer we've seen Jennifer play
mostly Knight to C6 at this point after
Knight to F3 we've seen that in her game
against Megan Lee she lost that we've
seen that in her game against abrahamian
she lost that as well so right now she
comes to the game and she says look I
want I'm in sole leadership position
right I want to cement my lead so all I
want to do is just make a draw I don't
want to take any unnecessary risks with
the black pieces I'm going to go for the
Petrov so she goes Knight to F6 now we
see the move d4 Knight takes C4 Bishop
to D3 D5 and not a d takes C5 which is
one of the main lines but Knight to E5
Knight D7 and this is what we have right
now Castle Bishop to D6 and the move
Knight to C3 and Knight takes C3 is on
the board now white has a couple of
options in the positions you can start
with the move C4 C6 take take and now
Knight C3 and this is a bit different
than what we're seeing in the game right
now because after you take on C3 I take
back you go Castle I go Queen H5 and
right now black usually goes for G6
gives up the pawn but now with the C
file open and with the pressure on the
Square C3 as well as the square H2 Queen
to C7 seems to equalize in the position
now
what we have in the position is not C4
C6 but rather Knight to C3 first so now
let's uh this leads to a very uh
different type of game I take C3 btc3
Castle is on at the board they're
following one of the main lines and now
white has continued with the move Queen
to H4 H5 put some pressure in the
position now G6 is no longer feasible of
course not because
Queen takes D5 right and now without any
pressure on the C file uh you don't have
enough compensation as black this is
just going to be an extra Pawn for a
white and very good position but what
you can do is play the move F5 now this
takes advantage of the fact that after
Queen to F3 the spawn on D5 is not going
to be feeble because I'm just simply
going to reinforce uh the defense with
the move C6 I still have the C Pawn on
the board so Queen F3 C6 and this is the
type of position that were most likely
headed towards now white has some ideas
Rook to be one put some pressure with A4
A5 on the pawn that's most likely going
to land on B6 C4 is also an idea in the
position and you want to take advantage
of the fact that black most likely had
to overextend with this move uh F5 it
leaves some squares behind so for
example I can go Bishop to F4 exchange
the dark Square Bishops and then try to
land something on E5 and play behind
that most potential uh Rook on E5 so
quite an intriguing position quite an
intriguing middle game growing in uh the
game between begin
or queen to H5 is on the board and the
leader in the lady section Jennifer and
we're most likely going to cf5 which
came rather quickly it's no secret of
course coach that you work with begum
how was her approach to this
all-important game today
um well we did expect Jennifer to play
Knight to C6 in fact we looked at some
Petrov as well
but for the most part we knew and we
know and Becky knows that this is going
to be a fight yeah no matter what I mean
Jennifer is a fighter she loves to put
pressure in the middle game positions
we've seen that after getting a terrible
opening position in her game against
a couple of days ago
Queen D3 E4 E5 horrendous right and she
fought her way back to a better position
so we knew that the outcome of the
opening is not going to be as
influential it's just simply going to be
a fight in the middle there yeah in any
case I would recommend all our viewers
to check the game if they missed it last
from the 10th round it was a great time
wow I mean it went back and forth and
Jennifer was losing out of the opening
she came back and she was um plus six
yes according the evaluation then she
was down minus three a draw it was crazy
but what I was impressed was that after
all these crazy games
most of the players stayed in the club
and they played some other you know
Blitz Games back house exactly it just
it's unbelievable how much energy they
have after such a game as with nazia I
would just go and just fall down you
know exactly they had fun I went to the
club as well and I saw Christopher you
and uh a Wonder Liang playing Blitz
house yes with
Julian and the the staff here
so our journalist yes and then Jennifer
came and I think some other also girls
came at the moment and you showed them
some positions right the problem
unbelievable like how much energy it was
really funny so I I set up the position
that Alice Lee had against Anna zetanski
yes and I said this position with
Bishops of opposite color there is a
tactic in this ending that Alice Mist
that could have won the game yeah yes or
get out of here you don't know what
you're talking about yeah yeah take a
look
and then they found it and they were
just like oh yeah I wanted to turn our
attention to Wesley so versus elshon
Wesley has a reputation as a very very
solid player but also his colleagues
kind of like uh are a bit jealous that
sometimes his opponents do strange
things he ends up winning material and
he wins a game it's like why do why does
he get so lucky and he wins a pawn well
it's prep and this what what what
um Christian show with Queen A4 this is
a nasty little uh Nuance in the position
because after C4 you're not defending
the pawn on E5 and I knew Alshon
wouldn't just go into an opening like
this and say I'm going to Bluff my way
no no no he's not that guy right exactly
and I was more than curious so I stayed
with the game a little bit and there
goes the pawn now you could just stop
right here and say exactly this is
what have I what am I doing here yes
until you start seeing these next few
moves okay the pawn goes to E5 the
Knight was chased to a lesser Square it
didn't really want to go to F3 where it
could be harassed some more so Knight C2
Knight C6 okay it's a hope I still have
a bond yes exactly now I harassed the
Knight on C2 again you kind of have no
choice you go be Knight to E3 the bishop
comes back to G6 and now you kind of
stop for just a second and you go okay
I'm a pawn down as black but please give
me one issue night you know I'll have
midnight on D4 I'll have good
development is it worth upon probably
not but this is the type of uh I wanted
to say counter play that you know you've
got free play you you you get very
active right and yeah use a logical it
it all comes from this idea of the
gambito the Gambit uh you give up
material for time yes
one two three four five verses one two
three four and it's black to move so you
know I don't know if you're going to
Castle short or you're going to Castle
long but you see what I have I have you
know good development not so easy to
Castle short like Bishop castling and
then Bishop on D2 is hanging right yes
so even I can prevent it in a way yeah
it's not so easy and again that the
night will come to D4 so there is
compensation there is a compensation
black does have some time and elshon you
know like doubtlessly put this through
his stockfish engines and said you know
like okay it's worth a shot okay it uh
well we'll we'll we'll we'll see if
that's true or not uh you had the Hans
Neiman position on your scoreboard for
just a moment there that was the F3 how
is it going for Hans uh well not so well
anymore let's take a look at what
happened so we left it at third move F3
he takes F3 you have to play yes if you
allow me to take on e4 and then Target
that with you one you're gonna lose that
pawn forget about it of course you have
to take on F3 Rook 2 uh F1 blitzed out
by hand so still within his preparation
King to D7 makes a lot of sense once
again it's all about getting that Knight
to C7 right you cannot do it immediately
because 96 Rook to E1 you're on a pimps
so you have to get off the E file with
the move King to D7 and in fact after
Rook F3 Knight to E6
an important move at this point in
important juncture in the position
because you can play what has played
Rook to E1 but unfortunately this seems
to lose the advantage after the move
Knight to C7 the best move in the
position was to actually and what is
once again you have to wonder what is
Black's idea in the position
threat Knight to C7 is one but there is
one big threat you want to take on G5
right because the Rook on H1 is not
protected so how do you do that you
actually just simply defend the Rook on
H1 with the move uh Rook to F1 and now
if you do go for the move Knight to uh
C7 I have the H Pawn protected compared
to the position that we have currently
in the game and I can start with the
move Bishop to F7 start targeting the
pawn on G6 which creates quite an
unpleasant situation for you I mean you
finally landed on the best square that
you could imagine a couple of moves ago
D5 yeah the Knight is happy but now you
have to move again to the Defender come
on G6 it's an unpleasant dilemma in the
position and after Knight to E7 I have
ideas of Rook to E1 still you're very
much tied up as a black this one is not
looking good then in fact the engine is
saying plus two so completely wow that's
the objective point of view for a white
but right now it's not so easy anymore
because you no longer have the Rook on
H1 so you don't have time to go Bishop 7
I will take on H4 and then you will have
some problems with upon D4 as well after
move Knight to B5 so not so easy anymore
for Hans unfortunately he missed a big
opportunity to have quite a large
Advantage out of the opening thank you
for that uh Christian wow what a move
Rook on F3 to F1 protecting against
Knight takes G5 yeah
that's not intuitive
at all yeah rookie one is the most
intuitive and by the way he played
rookie one after like a minute yes
he gets started to play very fast
somehow it's not a good sign yes I mean
you still should spend a little bit of
time especially in the position which is
new I don't think he really he had the
success against elshon by blitzing
al-shannon yes maybe he's pushing his
luck but yeah I'm with you on this one
sometimes it's yeah the classical chess
enjoy the classical chess features hello
everyone thank you for joining the show
but we also would like to invite you to
join our discussions we've really been
enjoying your questions yes and you can
stump us uh Anastasia Christian or
myself by asking the commentators how
did they do justice so you can follow
our social media accounts and Twitter
account as well Saint Louis chess club
is is the address and then you can ask
questions using the hashtag u.sgschamps
which you can see on the screens don't
forget also to follow YouTube channel of
St Louis chess club you you may not only
see the broadcast but if you missed some
interviews videos you can always check
them out and exactly and we have a
question all right let's see it here we
go this is from Daniel
degrees go
four okay so it's actually very nice
comment so yaser Anastasia and Christian
thank you for the awesome commentary
thank you awesome absolutely for your
comment and curious to hear what your
most memorable victory of your chest
career is
um I have a coin if you will one side's
heads one side sales for me my most
memorable victory was when I defeated
Anatoly karpov the reigning world chess
champion and the Phillips and Drew in
1982. I was the first world I was the
first American since Bobby Fischer the
world champion and all that gotta kamski
would come later blah blah blah but that
was really nice but the flip side of
that coin is like literally a you know a
few months before I had played Anatoly
karpov the first time ever yes and I had
this absolutely overwhelming positional
Victory win that made a draw
it was a memorable there was a memorable
win and a memorable Miss I see I all
both against the same player how about
yourself I understand your most
memorable Victory no it was one nice
Victory I had against in one Ukrainian
youth championship where I sacrificed
two Rooks in one game so I think this
was
my best games ever played so that's why
it's the most memorable it made it to
informator even oh very very nice I
showed you the other day remember in the
Eric's house a long time ago okay one
months ago but we were showing uh nepo
was showing also memorabilities
yes and there was a very nice evening
also they checked many games over silly
went to give you remember yes okay but
it was a different story so it was about
Christians Christian jumped in your most
memorable Victory my friend I mean I
have so many yes yes yes yes yes
is full I think one of them is against
an almost 2700 Alexander onlystruck it
was in Texas we were having one of these
closed Invitational events organized by
the university that I was attending at
the time University of Texas at Dallas
and he came as the visiting Grand Master
and he was much higher rated than
everybody else in the tournament I
managed to beat him actually quite a
smooth game with the white pieces in
Marie Lopez and after that he actually
told me hey you are special you you have
some understanding
and I felt good about it I felt good
about it of course Alexander ownership
was you know 2700 everybody knew he was
he was bringing the US championships and
I was just uh a low-key student at the
time so it was quite a memorable victory
for me Alexander actually was a U.S
champion and by the way it's a good
opportunity to send him best regards
absolutely absolutely big shout out to
uh and I also won that event
so that was a good question
yeah by the way you bet enough about you
what about your career
let's talk something else right
um what do you have in back of you
because I've got big great question
thank you for the setup that was very
very nice what do you have behind you
Christian I was looking at this game of
Fabi versus uh Jeffrey and the game has
transitioned into a completely different
type of structure so after I removed
Rook to C1 A4 5 we were discussing
probably white wants to take advantage
of the newly created weaknesses around
the queen side complex so with the move
Knight to A4 it makes a lot of sense
that you want to land the Knight on C5
and that's exactly what he did B5 Knight
to C5 Knight takes C5 a d takes C5 the
structure has changed now what is
changed in the position I see
specifically the score D4 for my knight
so the Knight is most likely going to
land on D4 what you can do in
preparation for that is just to play the
move a bishop to D7 Bishop to D7 Knight
to D4 and then maybe Knight to E4 and
we're going to have this type of
situations in which
I'm looking at the position and I see a
good night versus a bad Bishop but I
also see this weakness on C5 it would be
much worse for black if this Pawn would
actually be on B7 in the position uh
right now with the phone already on B5 I
have full control over my structure I'm
defending with the bishop the pawn the
base of my Pawn structure on C6 and
everything else is protected because of
that I also have ideas of targeting the
spot on C5 so I see this position as
quite balanced right now and I think
both of these players are understanding
that nevertheless this is going to be a
very long strategic middle game because
we still see the presence of a good
knight the Knight on D4 against a
potential bad Bishop on D7 so white in
my opinion still has a slight pull
all right thank you for that Christian
I'm just looking at the game between
begum and Jennifer uh the players have
blitzed out their moves all the way up
to Jennifer's F7 F5 and again uh Queen
F3
um Main Line uh the the most common move
but C3 C4 makes a lot of sense it's very
logical I have a double pawns on C3 and
C4 let me continue to solve one of those
weak weak pawns and maybe you know gain
some space uh open up the position like
let's say a bad move for black might be
a move like for example a7a6 and here
you see me gaining space you're kicking
I'm kicking the bishop back and suddenly
you know you can start to see that
White's position he's really she will
really be enjoying
um the more active pieces so after C4
the most common those I want to say just
take it okay
I move and what's good for you could be
good for me you can go back and try to
pursue
you could do it the second time around
but uh another interesting
um approach for from Black's point of
view is that if you're afraid yes of the
move C5 and you know kicking the bishop
off the diagonal well I can reinforce
the puck
and then finally another move I actually
find the most interesting of all of the
choices is Queen F6 the the idea behind
Queen F6 is as obvious as it looks I
want to take this Pawn on you know like
please take my Pawn I'll take your pawn
and oopsie Daisy The Rook will be
hanging as will be the pawn and if you
defend the pawn on D4 with for example
move like C3 here the slight difference
is before I had no choice yes I had to
go King
now
thanks to the queen coming to F6 maybe
this move is a little bit more annoying
than the other one if you drop back then
I can for example play like C5 Jennifer
has gone into quite the thing after the
move C4 as she's weighing her options
should she take on C4
Queen F6 C7 C6 the amazing thing is each
line is very very different from the
other by the way
they can fall asleep
what just happened here I think Vega uh
what did you do did you did you
overwhelm her with your with your
preparation I think Bank of just like
I think she's enjoyed her sleep even I I
don't know what's happening there she
does that sometimes uh during trainings
also really really good yes
she follows asleep all the time yes she
thinks that she's doing some thinking
with her eyes closed but I know what
she's doing she's taking a nap do you
remember this famous story when Marcus
Carlson fall asleep during the game the
world championship match in Sochi in
2014 against vishan yes yes it happened
I mean it was everywhere in all news
that he really like made this really
nice snap yes and then he because it
looked like he was really sleeping and I
remember also vision and looking at him
you know very surprisingly and the press
conference I wanted to ask them a
question like if he's snored or not and
if you interrupted you the second
process of we shall not I mean no but
really the pictures were everywhere in
this video when he is like you can find
it it's so funny nice nice so if the
world champion can sleep during the
match you can imagine exactly we all
have uh equal rights is it this kind of
sign of disrespect of course oh
absolutely I think what I I I in my
experience it never happened
Arthur bisquire I just quickly tell a
story Arthur bisquire as playing Bobby
Fischer yes
and um Bobby the night before had been
hustling five minute chess to way way
way up early in the morning and
um during the game Bobby fell asleep
really yeah and there was Arthur
wondering what he should do you know his
sleeping looking at the clock looked and
he decided
I'm Arthur bisquire I don't want to win
a game against my lowly rated Junior
opponent hey Bobby Bobby wake up
according to Arthur Bobby took a yawn
reached out made a move slapped the
clock and in the game appeared in my 60
memorable game
the moral of the story your opponent's
gonna sleep yes
sleeping dogs lie uh what do you got for
us Christian Irina crush is in trouble
whoa Nazi by kids at right now check
this out
C4 this seems to have been played and
probably you know uh this game's
yesterday especially one Kasparov versus
kamsky yes in 1989 right 85. you must
know this this hurts right this hurts
exactly and the engines definitely agree
and confirm that assessment is plus 1.6
right now I'm threatening to go D6 right
if you take on B3 I take back now I
still have two threats in the position I
have root takes A7 coming as well as D6
you most likely have to defend against
uh D6 I'm going to pick the pawn back on
A7 and I'm going to have a dominating
position so after D5 maybe you have to
defend with the move Knight V8 but I
just simply pick it up on C4 restore the
material balance in the position and
Knight to D2 is coming Knight V4 is
coming I'm going to eliminate whatever
Fortress you're trying to plant on D6
and you're just simply going to be much
worse look at this monster on B2 ready
to Target your G7 Square this one is not
looking good for uh Irina crushing right
now Irina is down to her last
well 59 minutes sure but Nazi is uh one
hour and 12 minutes on the clock and she
seems to know what she's doing in the
position and
if Irina loses this one and Jennifer
draws or maybe even wins her game
against begging it it feels like she's
running away with the event creating
separation between herself and her
nearest Rivals yes I really of course
needs uh to win or make a draw in order
to stay a result but again
that round 12 tomorrow how big does it
Loom as Arena will be facing uh Jennifer
in that round 12. you know one of the
things and uh
here again
uh shocking result in their head-to-head
Anastasia absolutely I mean come on no I
would never imagine no I was shocked
when I saw this Graphics I was I was
really surprised I didn't know that
Jennifer has such a great score against
say time uh U.S Champion I mean they
played three games only and she won two
games out of three not at all one of the
things we had dinner last night with
Maurice and one of the reasons that
Maurice in particular loves these U.S
championships because it's not just the
the best of the best in the US chess you
also have these Juniors yes versus the
veterans and it's like the veteran Wiley
veterans wanting to beat the kids when
they're young and the inexperienced kids
want to show the June the seniors they
don't know what they're doing I'm loving
the game of Alice Lee versus
I mean her approach in my opinion the
opening no H7 and H6 Knight C6 doesn't
fit but she trying to get her Junior
out of the book and into a position that
maybe Alice doesn't know very well
because it's so uncommon takes on C4
Queen A4 E5 yeah
recommended exactly she gets in her
break yes at the end of the day right
this bishop on G2 is looking really good
until you see just a moment just a
moment that move that was the move that
I wanted to show so like the pawn on C6
really is a brick wall and Alice I just
love her approach I don't care about
your brick wall I'm gonna break it down
B4 let's go uh B5 is on Alice's agenda
Rook d8 Queen C2 Bishop E6 and I think
we've caught up with the players after
this move Bishop E6 and again this kind
of uh veteran versus junior approach and
well you've heard me to say that in
those positions with majorities on on a
Flank versus in the center I tend to
light the center before you affordable
things exactly but on the other hand I
really really love development white
shouldn't be in too big a hurry to play
moves like E4 and F4 because
essentially blacks verse she's connected
her Rooks before white has so a move
like E4 you could see very quickly that
uh
backfire and District Square is weak D3
specific situations but also you can see
oh you know I don't like where it goes
exactly so we'll keep an eye on this one
for sure as again uh Alice Lee with if
any of her if Jennifer
wobbles if Marina wobbles
let's get going so a big match over to
you uh and you've got the Ray Robinson
game man I I do it's a French I don't
really understand what's happening but I
can read the time and Ray Robson is down
to his last 42 minutes against one hour
and 25 minutes that's a big that's that
is a huge time difference right right
now and Ray has been thinking and trying
to figure out what to do and this
position maybe we can connect and
network about the French discuss the
French a little bit after the game maybe
he can give me some tips because he
spent a lot of time trying to understand
the position and he came up with this
idea of playing the move Knight to F1
what this is hinting at is that most
likely you're going to leave the queen
side unattended and what you're going to
try to focus as white and this is
exactly what he's doing right now is the
king side the side where you have a more
space due to the fact that pawn is on E5
a bit more advanced Bishop to IV was
played I'm envisioning this Knight
landing on E3 Bishop drops back to H2
the Knight drops back to D2 and then
some sort of a pawn storm on the king's
side at the same time
what is black going to do most likely
going to go something like Bishop to A4
you have ideas of even trying to open up
the queen side with the move uh Queen to
C7 B5 A5 and then B4 uh but you have to
be very careful because your king is
there right right so that might be a bit
too dangerous what you could do is start
try to counteract uh the expansion uh
coming from White on the king side with
the moves such as Queen to C7 and follow
that up with the move F5 very intriguing
position I have to say in this game
between a wonder who definitely is very
well prepared coming into uh this round
and Ray Robson who must be thinking I
think I need to win this one because
Fabi is well half Point ahead and he
might be running away with the event I
want to win this one I only have one
extra white after this game so I need to
take advantage of those extra whites it
doesn't look really happy though no it
has been spending a lot of time Rey is
one of those poker players he doesn't
really change his expression is not as
expressive as a Hikaru Nakamura openly
wears his emotions on a slave he he's
cagey I just wanted to say in that
position you have on your board
Christian yes one of the
ideas of David bronstein was like you
said to put the queen on C7
to put the Knight on A4 not the bishop
but to put the Knight on A4 is going to
be nice 98 and then ah okay so leave the
Knight on B3 leave the Knight on B3 but
go ahead put the Knight on Ce you like
play something like this yeah sure we'll
get the night away for yes and Bishop
takes A3 ah um
and French defense players are are
joyful to be happy
you've made so many
zeros by yourself I don't
know I know it's terrible it's terrible
they don't appreciate the depth it's not
the idea also what I can do is whenever
you land on A4 thank you very much
only one result
exactly all the games uh Christian hold
the thought because what we're going to
do is we're going to go to Q Boutique
first and we're going to tell us what's
going to happen on key Boutique and then
another break what's today what's
happening yes so today we have a Champs
jacket yes the one which I think
Jennifer Jennifer is wearing yeah she's
wearing today and it's available on
cubic now we're available this handsome
sport jacket in men's and women's sizes
featuring screen printed Champs logo on
the front and the screen printed St
Louis chess club blogger on the back so
we can shop online right now at cubic
shop and we got some of them right I
have a red one I have the athletic cut
we know that you like it yes yes very
very very nice and really beautiful
actually I love the colors the really
great and on our break we had actually
sat down beforehand with the players and
asked the players what's it like coming
back to over-the-board tournaments yay
it's not everything online over the
board tournaments I'm playing here in St
Louis these were their reactions
what's your favorite part about the U.S
championships being held here in St
Louis well it's my first CS championship
and my favorite part is that it's so
long I really love playing this
old-fashioned long tournaments and the
fact that is in San Luis it's extremely
convenient for me because I live here
well I've only played one US
Championship that wasn't here I played
in 2008 that was my first one then 2009
I moved to St Louis and it's obviously
by comparison I could tell it was much
nicer and it's very professionally run
the price one's very good and uh you
know hey one of my us Championship here
once uh felt amazing I love it it's
cultural it's a lot of strong players
playing and his chest and it's all
together it's a fantastic experience I'm
just glad that for the first time part
of it
um well first of all I mean St Louis is
one of the nicest places I've been to in
the US and
it's kind of like been a routine for me
the last 10 years I've been coming every
year playing it's pretty much a second
home to me now yeah in a way it's um
there's very little pressure in an event
like that because you know I'm just
happy to to be here playing and uh you
know it's an enjoyable experience pretty
much no matter the result it's an
especially important tournament and this
year it's even longer than usual more
players so it feels like it'll be more
challenging but also more rewarding well
it's my first U.S Championship but uh
I really like St Louis I've spent a lot
of time here in the past few months and
my next results in St Louis
so it feels like not home but there's a
level of normalcy to playing Gear that I
don't get you know traveling around
Europe This is the closest thing I have
to home because I'm living in hotels so
the Chase Park Plaza is like my my
second home so it's nice to have
familiarity and of course just planned
or good conditions you know it's just
great to be in the atmosphere of St
Louis and you know the conditions here
are wonderful for the players and just
to be able to play all the top players
in the world is really unique for me and
it's something I'm really looking
forward to I generally just like the
atmosphere it feels since I've been here
so many times it feels like really
familiar I'm just ecstatic to be playing
at the U.S Championship like I didn't
really even expect to play this year but
I'm just really excited well I think in
general for me I've always enjoyed
Forest Park a lot so anytime I come to
St Louis I make sure to to make as many
visits there as I can just explore the
nature and all it has to offer
especially now this time of year the
weather is great and yeah I look forward
to to venturing there again the
tournament just keeps getting stronger
every year which makes it harder for me
to try to win but
that's probably probably the best part
is actually that I was just kept getting
stronger all the time I mean back in
2015 there was like Hikaru and maybe
gotta monishook but back then like I had
a real chance of winning now I still
have a chance of winning but there's
there's lots of more competition so it's
forced me to try to improve myself as
well so I think that's that's really
great that tournament just keeps getting
better every year it's the capital of
chess if I would save them for the world
so it's amazing to play here every
single year well a couple of things
first of all I like the fact that uh
um I live here so when I'm when I'm
playing here I get the support from from
my people from my family which is kind
of unusual in the Chess World because
you are always traveling and I also like
the fact that uh the atmosphere that
it's created here it's usually great and
uh that's that's also I think helpful
for chess like for example you are in
the middle of a tournament which is
normally very serious and you know it's
super competitive obviously and all that
but then you get to hang out with great
people like you know the organizers like
Joey and Tony and and Yasser and Rex
himself and and just for a few hours you
forget about the the tournament and you
have a good time and it's very friendly
and very nice and and that's I think one
of my favorite Parts well it really
feels like my home uh or basically my
second home so we're only an hour flight
away from Minnesota and I've been coming
here in and out for the last seven eight
eight years Years also I went to college
here 10 years ago also St Louis has been
hosting world-class tournaments the
singfield cup Etc so when you come here
you know you will be challenged
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
we have round 11 of US championships so
we have one result so far Sam schenkland
made a draw a quick draw against Leonard
yeah the repetition was not the same
liking but he had made a double Pawn
sacrifice at that point and it was
probably the prudent decision to go for
a draw how about women's results coming
in today pardon me the standings so we
don't have results still at the moment
and so it means Jennifer you is still
leading with seven points out of 10 and
then we have Arena Craft on the second
place and many many players chasing them
on the third place including them and
who is playing Jennifer yes for the
first place today and when we left it we
had seen this position after C4 and this
is where Jennifer went into a bit of a
tank because she's got these very
different choices including C6 yes D
takes C4 and her choice which was Queen
F6 it actually your choice yeah so you
said that you would prefer to play look
I love development I love connecting the
Rooks doing so with a gain of tempo I
mean that's always high on my wish list
uh c2c3 captures and this was why
Jennifer took the time she did because
she had invested it in this position
came to the conclusion that the bishop
on E6 is very well placed and I really
do not like begum's choice in response
to Bishop E6 she chose to play the move
Bishop D3 into my mind this move just
doesn't fit with what white is trying to
do why I'm a pond Grabber yes look at
the position where's a weak Pawn where
is the weakness uh here for on for for
white what is white
of course
therefore I'm going to play the move
Queen F7 I'm going to invite the trader
Queens I'll recapture with the King
because in my mind's eye I would like to
have G6 rookie 8 and Bishop to D5 if you
don't trade Queens if you come back for
example Queen to E2 well you're putting
your queen under some right on the open
file right and if
and if I go Queen D1 Bishop A2 but what
cut your eye in this game uh Christian
no just to uh continue on this tangent
about this game Queen to F7 by the way
according to the engines is not the best
move because in fact it considers this
end game as better for white really yes
yes yes and I was trying to understand
why also okay slightly better for a wife
that much better A4 and try to take as
much space on the queen side as possible
now how would you respond to this move
uh yes would you go A5 would you go B6
how would you tackle this challenge
that's Brewing on the queen side with
this expansion exactly I probably a
little bit awkwardly but B6 B6 yeah yeah
so what I think and why I think she did
not want to exchange the light Square
Bishops is that she's eyeing this Pawn
on F5 and saying look with the respawn
D3 at least your Bishop only six despite
the fact that you have some weaknesses
that you can play with you also have to
find your own Pawn structure and with
the bishop on D3 I will also have ideas
of potentially expanding via C4 D5 put
some pressure on your pieces as it is
still the position is very very close uh
to equality and I have to say Jennifer
you with black pieces in the lead with
Irina Crush actually losing or at least
being much worse in her game must be
quite content with the outcome of the
opening she's very close to achieving
full equality if she hasn't already
achieved that and uh well yeah right now
she's the sole leader and could
potentially be looking at extending her
lead after this game
all right uh the other question I had
actually in this position uh question
was Queen F7 that has my immediate you
know thumbs up I like it very very very
much you just heard me a moment ago
saying I I like this idea of G6 and
Bishop uh D5 and just kind of
controlling things
the desirable F4 of course hangs my uh
Checkmate so that's why could I play G6
and play for F4 and okay let me just
make a move for white I don't know if
this is a good or a bad move I'll do it
and I'll go no no but Queen F3 I have to
go oh excuse me Queen well I think I
have to stay active as much as possible
and once again I believe one of my main
plans is oh you're gonna give me the
pawn I'm not I I want what if I take it
okay I'll take it that's the problem is
yeah I just I see a pawn I've learned
from the best uh
no probably I have to well the problem
then if I play C6 I'm worried you will
play Bishop F4 yes as soon as possible
and then yeah and 95 Queen G3 maybe okay
now imagine this position if I could get
to play F5 F4 that was why oh that's
right the Bishops yeah that was what
that was all about uh we'll keep it very
very watchful eye but hold on you said
Arena's losing I mean Arena hasn't
improved her situation let's just put it
that way a Christian uh bring that game
up on your board and tell us why it's
bad for arena well I mean after this
last move Knight to E4 and by the way
she was probably supposed to go with the
move A4 which has been played so this
position has uh been reached twice uh
before in 2004 and 2019 in both of those
games I would assume these are
correspondence games uh A4 was the move
play now with the same idea you can play
the move Knight to E4 you try to
exchange the blockading piece the Knight
on D6 what's the best way to exchange
that via B5 so Knight to B5 right now is
a big big threat in the position not
only that but I'm also targeting the
pawn on A7 so you have to be extremely
careful as black if you play the move A6
you just created another weakness in the
position the pawn B6 so this is even
worse than what we see right now Landing
in the position which is Knight to E4
this was the last move played by a Nazi
by kids Irina is still in trouble even
after Knight to E4 forget about A4 A4
might come later in the game anyway
she's in trouble right now
um I'm looking at a position
objectively she's plus one but from a
practical perspective it might be even
worse than that this one is not looking
good because the blockade because I run
D6 yes yes being forcibly traded off all
right and you can see she doesn't like
her no no no no no no no she's not happy
with her position no no not not one bit
a game uh I'm keeping my eye on as well
as Rue Yang Yan versus Megan Lee now
again Megan Lee what did you say she had
like yeah
it was actually one of the leaders even
maybe even soldiers and then some
something happened and like yeah she
lost two games and she fell off the lead
okay uh I'm looking at the game that
Megan is playing right now Megan was
black against reunion and this move
wrote by Ru Yang uh the the last move H2
H3 is a little bit disconcerting uh
let's put it that way I mean you know it
wouldn't be wonderful if we all got to
make moves you know like bipana D4 is
hanging like please defend the pawn like
put your put your knight on a bad Square
put your queen do something like this
give me a time to set up for my queen
coming to H4 and let me play F6 in the
nicest possible way and Megan is gleeful
to move h2h3 on the other hand that's
really really annoying the bishop can't
move because
the the Knight just hangs
um you don't have time to take on D4
Knight takes D4 is just a peace
sacrifice for an empty Bluff this is
yeah like Bishop to five I mean how many
pounds
it's not enough it's not enough and
after for example Bishop B5 Knight F3
it's white who's taking over the attack
and this I don't like it yes which means
you have to play Knight takes E3 which
helps white uh buttress up the pawn on
D4 now your Bishop is under attack and
so you start to think to yourself well
maybe I should play H5 but then after
Bishop to the D3 once again you find
yourself kind of on this uh how do you
say uh you're kind of compelled to make
these moves that don't really fit into
the position your Bishop is now passive
you're not getting in C5 I could start
with B4 but in truth I do like this idea
of Rook F4 Rook coming to F1 and you
start to see that
you know rueyang is the one happening
Yes actually absolutely yes I don't like
this bishop 1 B6 at all I don't either
exactly so maybe you explained really
well like this is exactly the situation
Bishop against Knight and this bishop is
not so great look at the bones of white
they're all placed on the dark squares
in the center so this move h2h3 just
comes at a very very bad time I want to
go quickly to the game of Talia
Bishop takes D4 yeah look at this what
what come back to the mega League game
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa yes Bishop D4
so now if you take on G4 you take within
probably serialize the position is not
really great so yes now the idea Knight
is recheck oh sorry
63 I already called Collectibles they
are ready
wow
for checkmate holy smokes just a second
wait a minute
uh Bishop take I was only focused on
nighttime me too before Knight takes E34
and that does I mean here I can double
attack the bishop and the Knight but I'm
not winning a piece because you have 92
check but also the more direct Knight
takes now wait a minute wait a minute
yes
um uh fortunately white has a very
confusing move now
she could move her Bishop yin yang from
all these threats and this
Bishop is hanging and this night the
bishop is gone so what you have to give
it Bishop I think you're just lost yes
you're completely lost right now yes and
what that's only two pawns that's only
two pounds it's not enough Knight F3
Knight controls the square F3 so you can
jump to H4 but it's not actually
creating any threats exactly
bishop and
so Megan played the move Bishop takes D4
has she miss Bishop F4 but did she have
any alternatives I thought it was night
taking just Knight takes E3 and you end
up in the position with probably Bishop
on B6 yes which is a bit unpleasant yeah
it is yes it is but the bad news for uh
Megan is like white has no choice Bishop
takes D4 black is just winning Pawn
takes black is just winning after Knight
takes E3 Rue yangan has to find out of
elimination before and then actually
Megan again is in trouble she made loose
maybe the sword game in the role okay
for example Queen this one now Bishop is
here again so I went Queen H4 just to
try to impress the and takes takes this
guy's hanging now you G3 would be oops
because you cannot take it with Queen
takes but perhaps just Bishop H2 bishop
and then I go back Bishop G3 oh that's
something
yeah
can I get your signature on this
question uh I will probably give it to
you this at this time yeah so what a
minute so what happens after Queen h4m
pursuing you don't give up so easily no
no no no okay maybe if you once you take
on G4 okay
I think you have to take of course not
the bishop is Bishop D3 is that it
D3 just Bishop D3 with the idea that
Knight is hanging right and with the
idea that now
G3 and now it's just three years not
Bishop no once again
yes because F3 is protected yes I mean I
could have played it as well it just
looks so wild
the game continues still right right so
that's why I'm saying maybe I could have
played it with a [ __ ] Pawn H2 it looks
ugly so take and just do the initial
idea with Beach page 2. the initial idea
yeah now Knight H4 now G3 it looks ugly
yeah
it's very ugly but maybe it's sufficient
wow uh okay you have you need to have a
really really good nervous system
so maybe bishop I mean just how many
bones already that's three that's number
three yes that is the three parts and
you've got a kind of initiative Brewing
over here still three wow it's not that
it's not easy
well I can go rookie one and probably
Queen H3 Bishop F1 drop the bishop there
but okay I don't think I'm getting
checkmated but you still have three
points three pounds is a three pounds
this is going to be a fight when she
played the move Bishop takes D4 pardon
me when Megan uh played the move Bishop
D4 uh how much time did she have it
looks like they're about the same yes at
the moment I can see that it's 50 no no
50 versus 50. something like this 40
something yes quite the fight going on
over there and what is happening to Ray
Robson and uh it's a surprise one
example why I hate the French
am I in the position of the knights okay
okay this is move 12 yes
fast forward like seven moves okay yes
so far so good
we're the knights the knights are on the
same position that they started seven
moves ago and you played one two three
four moves with the Knights right and
you got into the same position and now
you're worse and you're kind of this is
the correct you're fine that's why I
hate playing the French yes playing
against the French as well because
sometimes you have to make this type of
ugly Maneuvers all for what to get this
bishop out to G3 to face uh two points
it makes no sense the French my goodness
because you didn't listen to Yasser you
have to put your phone on Twitch five
okay you guys this great story so
goofeld Edward gulfeld the famous grand
master from Soviet Union he's playing in
some Ukrainian team championship
and it's one of those Team Championships
where you've got the men and women and
apparently there was a very very
attractive woman playing next and Edward
was looking at her with loving eyes you
know for four hours and his opponent
shocked it and the opponent claimed
three times repetition
on the board
and kufeld didn't want to give up her
seat where he was Charmed by this lady
and so he began to make an argument that
there wasn't three move repetition
because it was the king's Rook
that had been on the Square in one
position okay and it was the Queen's
Rook that was been on the Square in the
other position so so here watching the
two nights
it's the king's night on Glee dude
what are the rules for that what are the
rules for that no idea
the Arbiters were so confused and Edward
was talking to the lady as best he could
I think this morning before he got
thrown out it's probably a drawer
because the position looks exactly the
same it doesn't matter he's making this
argument it wasn't the same
Rooks
love it
lost the woman and Drew became
terrible I mean just these things
sometimes they work and sometimes they
don't work so good that's a good story
uh nice what do you have for us in the
Wesley sew game well it seems like
Wesley finally managed to stabilize the
position and still upon up uh right now
and this last move Knight to D5 seems to
be putting a lot of pressure on uh black
species because I'm finally finding good
squares for my own pieces right I got
the Knight to D5 I'm going to get this
bishop to C3 you're not giving me any
checks on this side and I mean the onus
is on you to find a way uh to prove your
compensation
well that's that's another reason why
open up the C5 is so important because
now I can go B4 you move the Knight oh
you move the bishop away I go C5 and I
close the position keep it closed so
like this C5 and the position is great
for y in fact it's pretty much almost
winning maybe now in five
[Laughter]
yes no I understand I was just thinking
about taking Bishop C5 sometimes and
Rook A1 but maybe it doesn't work now
that you actually found a good move 97.
97 and pick up the bishop if I take
first on D5 then Knight is not defending
group on D1
I see what you're saying yeah so you
want to do something like this and now I
can go B4 and then if I go C5 you go A5
but still okay
A3 now and I can take it and Bishop C5
yes yes and okay one of the ones very
nice very nice yeah the difference is
that probably at this point I'm just not
going to go away 300 yes probably you
will just it's all about the difference
in pieces right and now you don't have
the best piecing for you
show the viewers what honest does here
is yeah she wanted this skewer very nice
yeah yeah and Rook A1 check and now with
the exchange of the Knight on D5 this
Knight is not defending on D1 yes so
this is the king B2 and you will take
the rookies very nice yes yes yes to
improve my variation unfortunately a
Christian understood it earlier and he
didn't play history he didn't go to the
Trap okay he's a very mean person yeah
and uh by the way I I spoke to the
international chief Arbor about getting
you wanted for for fair commentary I
think is what we were talking about it
and uh Chris said and I quote he said
look the players are my responsibility I
have nothing to do with the commentators
get out of here I'm not I'm not playing
but we discussed some other
opportunities like to have special
chairs for the community that was a
difference a different discussion anyway
I learned from the best after 10 days
working was so great
finally I learned something we
too
um hold on uh who else is in the we went
through Megan's position which is great
crazy I wanted to say Talia she's on the
outside looking and she's playing
against ashrita who's shrieth has had a
roller coaster ride she started terribly
just like completely she lost three out
of her first four games or something
like that but then she snapped back she
won a couple in three games oh yes but
then something bad happened again so uh
at the moment
she's well yes it doesn't have that many
boys trying to make another comeback
three and a half points yes so she won
like three games it means and then she
kind of lost all the other right wow
what an event are you serious because
this is a really crazy event so she
plays against Thalia who won three games
in a row and was in a very very good
mood
I lost three games I won three games
right but now I'm looking at the
position
and first blush at least from ashwitha's
point of view I mean her last move
rooked to uh C8 sounds a very important
alarm that C5 takes D4 and Rook takes C2
is on her agenda and she's saying yes I
understand you want to play F5 yes I
understand the Knight on E5 is good I
understand also that with a rook lift
you can get at my king but it who gets
there first of the threat yes C4 and C3
thank you and see because of this what
you just pointed out C4 C5 C4 followed
by C4 C3 forking the bishop as well as a
knight probably is going to force the
move d4 take C5 well the good news for
Talia is that that does open up her
diagonal and Knight takes C5 and
no B4 excuse me B maybe maybe it's not
possible to take oh no forks from
everywhere everywhere
oh that means that oh yeah that wasn't
what I wanted to do though because I
wanted to I was hoping that from
shritha's point of view that the darks
were Bishops could be traded and then
she would neutralize but if I have to
play Bishop takes C5 that's not exactly
what I wanted do we have and we do have
uh yeah
so to repeat what you just said three
wins in a row let's tell you coming into
wow yes okay she's blazing yes it still
doesn't mean anything yes sir the
results
everything is still possible I guess but
yeah you feel this definitely extra
confidence exactly three in a row uh all
right well we'll definitely keep an eye
on this now I have to recalibrate as to
what I was thinking with this uh D this
position I was I was actually thinking a
shritha was for choice I was thinking
that the Rook uh was landing on C2 and
causing an accident this night on D2
should be on E5 you know what I mean
yeah I understand you're kind of
something is wrong with uh Harmony of
the pieces right yes at the moment well
just in time to I don't know Place some
kind of music by the way okay one oh
yeah just to just to show you that
doesn't work this time you cannot take
this phone the lady is trapped you got
your hands caught in the cookie jar okay
that one and and let's jump to Christian
who's with uh a special guest my best
man my wedding wow yes thank you yes sir
yes we are indeed with the international
Master John Donaldson 14th time uh the
team captain of the U.S Olympic team
historian extraordinaire and uh just
simply a great guy John welcome to the
show tell us a bit about what you're
doing here in St Louis right now uh well
I'm going to give a talk tomorrow
evening and it's going to be on Bobby
Fischer and Boris basket it'll tie in
with the exhibition that they're having
right now at the World Chess Hall of
Fame and my theme of this talk will be
uh Bobby and Boris their similarities
and a lot of people you know would
immediately think you know Boris being
raised in the Soviet Union and Bobby
being raised in the United States that
aside from chess they really wouldn't
have much in common but but in fact
there are quite a few similarities in
their lives and so I'll be discussing
that and the staff of the World Chess
Hall of Fame they assembled a large
number of interesting photos that will
accompany the talk and that match was
actually quite influential for your
Cheska reader as well you started uh
chess you joined the chess club when the
match started as well is that correct it
is correct yes Christian I I became a
member of the Tacoma chess club
and it's a city about 30 miles south of
Seattle and it's sitting for you know
175 000 people and when I walked through
the doors of the Tacoma chess club in
the fall of 1972 they had 200 members
and the club was open you know like
seven days a week and it was just
hopping and I think that I might have
you know been a continued to be a
lifelong chess player if I hadn't gone
to that club but but I do know that
because I did go there that it really it
really got me off to a great start and
of course uh one of the players that I
quickly met up was was Yasser who you
know was a little bit younger but but
you know he's from Seattle but we saw
him off in Tacoma for tournaments tell
us about the yes or is he a good guy or
not so much I mean I've been spending
the last few months around him I'm not
sure about that answer well I can tell
you this I've known him now for uh just
about 50 years and I think that during
that time I maybe seen him not smile
five times
that's pretty good yes sir I remember
John we played in the U.S junior
championships
and was it Walla Walla Washington uh we
were on the east side and you put my
pillow in the freezer
that was in the 1974 Washington State uh
junior closed and uh besides uh Yasser
Eric tangborn a future International
master was playing so by you know the
Northwest standards it was you know two
future items in one world-class player
it was a pretty competitive tournament
uh and
Yasser was already so much better than
all of us and well to be fair also in
Wenatchee Washington it was maybe 100
degrees that day that after he like just
killed like three of us in a row we
decided he needed we needed to cool him
off so while he was out swimming we put
all this clothing in the freezer
that is quite amazing what her friends
[Laughter]
now John you've been the team captain
for the US Olympic team so many uh times
what's the most difficult part of that
job you're dealing with so many great
players so many egos as well in the team
what is the most uh well I would say
this I would say that you know obviously
we've had different types of teams we've
had some teams where they were rated
like this last time and in 2018 and 16
where they're rated first or second in
the field and then we've also had teams
in the past that have been you know
rated like eighth or or ninth that were
more evenly balanced
and I would say the main thing is that
all the players you know need to feel
feel comfortable that they need to feel
that they're part of the team and I
would say that one thing I've been very
fortunate is that we've never really had
any players play in those 14 olympiads
that have Captain that have been like
problematic that sort of put their
individual results over the team so it
you know for me it's it's actually made
it a pretty easy job uh but sometimes
there you know there's certain
challenges I mean this recent event in
Chennai obviously we were really hoping
for more than we achieved and I've
thought about that a lot the
the last couple months you know like
like every day pretty much you know and
uh you know it it definitely you know
the the tournament was organized as I'm
sure all your viewers know on on a
relatively short notice the uh uh you
know originally was going to be in haunt
him on Sisk then it was going to be in
Moscow then the pandemic happened and
then uh they're you know it looked like
after the invasion in Ukraine that there
would be be no Olympiad and then the
Indians offered to jump in with like
four months to go and it was just uh you
know this is something that normally
takes the country a couple years to put
together I mean there's there were close
to 200 countries competing in this past
Olympiad and uh it initially it wasn't
clear how it would work out I mean I
know Brian Doyle he at the time he was
the handling the U.S Chess Federation
side and it was very complicated I think
we found out our hotel like four days
before the Olympiad and some of the
players like vegan she got her visa like
you know like five days before she left
so there's a lot of stress but once we
arrived in Chennai the the Indians were
incredibly you know gracious very
generous hosts uh and you know they did
everything they could to make us
comfortable I'd say that the only two
things that they couldn't control were
the weather and covet and uh in the case
of uh the weather it was just really
really hot I mean it was like 90 degrees
which all right for St Louis that's not
so bad but yeah but but it seemed like
it was I thought you know St Louis can
get pretty humid but this was like on
another level uh but of course it all
teams you know you know encountered this
heat it wasn't just our team that did
the other thing was covid and that was
kind of a mixed bag because on the one
hand you have all these chess players
that desperately want to
come together and to play in the
olympiads such a special event but on
the other hand you know uh in India they
were having a pretty serious outbreak in
the southern part of India and you know
just in general olympiads where players
come from all over the world usually
somewhere in the world it's like you
know flu season or what have you and so
the net result was that there were a
fair number of players that were sick on
our team that was a big challenge it was
a big Challenge and this Olympiad it
definitely was if you look at our
lineups pretty much the first half of
the term and I thought it made sense you
know everybody gets one free day but the
second half of the tournament for the
most part
it was like who is healthy because you
only have one reserved player and Lavone
in particular he was really uh I mean he
couldn't play the last you know two
rounds and and arguably he shouldn't
have played before that he just he
wanted to play he wanted to help the
team but he just was really really sick
difficult moments in India but let's
talk about your talk uh that is
happening on uh Thursday if I'm not
mistaken and we do have some highlights
and some graphics for you tell us what
are the takeaways for a Tuesday in fact
uh well I would say that uh
one thing that should be interesting for
this lecture for even the most die-hard
Bobby Fisher's fan is there'll be some
photos that they want to have seen of
him before so I think that would be one
thing that would be special I think
another thing that will be uh unique is
there'll be a number of photos of Boris
baskey especially from earlier news
career that will be
shown and you know in this match the 72
match
you know Fisher usually always gets you
know front and center and spaski's kind
of the you know the gentleman but but he
was the good loser you know The Whipping
Boy but he behaved so nobly uh but in
this particular case uh there will be
also a lot of attention on on spaski and
I think that that's only fair because he
had an incredible run from like about
1964 to 1972 where he you know won the
ozone in 64 and he went through the
candidates twice he lost his first world
championship match by The Narrows of
margins to petrosion and then managed to
defeat him so that will uh be brought up
and oh by the way I I have to say this
is one of my favorite Parts about the
current show in St Louis those uh uh
yeah it's the furniture from uh uh Jack
Collins apartment and it's I mean the
real chairs that Bobby and Lombardi and
uh Ray Weinstein all those guys would
sit on when they would play and analyze
with Collins and that's the actual chess
pieces that they actually used and you
know today young players they they gain
all their information playing on the
internet and and you know using chess
engines but for Bobby his uh
you know explosive growth occurred when
he visited Collins for you know the
better part of like six hours every day
uh for for that time period and just you
know
analyzed with him played with him people
would wander into the apartment you know
that were fellow chess players and
they'd look at the the games they had
played and it was kind of a who's who of
New York chess and that kind of a total
immersion was what really helped Bobby
you know make that leap from you know
like an expert to 2600 feet a candidate
level player John thank you very much uh
and I'm looking forward to it I will be
there tomorrow to watch the lecture I'm
really looking forward to it thank you
very much for joining us show thank you
thank you John thank you so much I'll
definitely be joining as well me too me
too it's really really fun by the way
John is one of those researchers that
really bugs me he's the guy that he's
not satisfied we were doing these books
on Akiba Rubenstein it was a two volume
set with Nikolai minnev and he would
double check and treble check all of the
resources making sure that the move
orders were precise the year years were
precise the spelling of his opponent's
nasers because it's like John you know
we've got deadlines come on come on come
on so he is really the researcher he
goes very very carefully through the
archives through through the source
material and it really pays off he knows
his stuff yes I was visiting this was
this exhibition but of course it will be
great to to hear many many details and
he also mentioned the that there will be
a lot of focus on Boris pusky I remember
one video where like Bobby Fisher
arrives to the match followed by the
hundreds of people and then Boris past
he comes alone you know
you know this video which you can see
also you can watch it on on the Hall of
Fame as well as well I just wanted to
turn our attention to the Naji pikachi
versus Arena crash game because I indeed
Naji got in all of those moves A4 A5 she
created a weakness and in these kinds of
positions uh you know where you've got
this wonderful wonderful protected past
Pawn you just have to look around and
you have to ask yourself is everybody
happy uh the bishop I think is kind of
happy I think the Rook is happy this
one's okay this guy's okay this guy is
not okay no this night this night is not
the happiness and I think Knight B1
Knight D2 to B1 to C3 so that you could
jump to B5 maybe even on a good day you
jump to A4 so there's a pawn so you you
want to make sure sure that everybody is
at their maximum and by the way because
the queen is a splocator the Knight
coming to C3 makes perfect sense in my
eyes because you could play Knight to B5
push the blockade and queen away I mean
I don't think it's like terrible
terrible terrible for arena I just say
yeah white is definitely for choice but
okay and again the Megan uh pardon me to
begin
again yes versus a Jennifer game I think
that that to my eyes I'm comfortable
when I'm black here you know I've just
she's her last move was just rookie oops
excuse me I've been speaking about Megan
began how is Megan after this remember
Bishop
no idea
I think but uh what Jennifer has done
with her last moves age six rookie said
of it is she's very carefully preparing
ideas of F5 F4
and and even possibly C7 C5 if I does if
if Jennifer goes C5 and provokes takes
Bishop takes she'll be really happy
she'll the pawns will be split and life
will be good for black so I think
Jennifer's doing just fine now what's
happening in the Rue Yang Yan game
Bishop F4
there's been a big pause going on here
here I think we looked at queen queen
you found this very very nice movement
but okay right now she's got a pawn but
she's losing a piece and well it's it's
it it's not clear that that black should
have gone through for all of these
complications
but uh let's turn it over to Christian
and the Ray Robson well I'm going to
continue my crusade against the friends
this broadcast is definitely emphasizing
that now Rook cb6 check this out the
next movie is pretty much forced for a
white and it's a very ugly move you have
to go Rook to A1 what is the correct
position why is it right in the position
for a black after I doubled on the B
file if you play a random move let's say
King to H3 which by the way is the
second best movie in the position what I
go Bishop A4 and you cannot defend the
pawn on B2 if you go Rook B1 I take on
A3 that's problematic way one you can
continue like this but I have a lot of
Pawns and you're in big trouble in this
room right because the pawns are just
going to be stormy uh down the board A6
King A7 Rooks move away or Rooks uh
infiltrate via the B file and then I'm
going to go B5 B4 you're not going to
stop those pawns so this one is pretty
ugly you have to go Rook to A1 to meet
Bishop A4
and you just have to stay like this we
can just like dance around and you have
to decide black has Joy at least it's
already it's so ugly how can people play
children
what is Wesley doing
what did Ray do he did it he played Rook
A1 he played Rook A1 yes A4 yes and we
could expect Rook A2 he he has to play
it okay now now the ugly part is what
you just said it's ugly it's depressing
but it's defending everything too it
does yes so the position is very close
to equality
um once you put your knight on C2 all
the pieces are more or less placed what
a moral victory for French defense
players right yes exactly I mean I
always have a draw now let me see if I
should play for the win right Christian
absolutely yeah sure I mean we all love
the French Christian is a good example
of when you don't understand the opening
you just kind of just choose
what else do you have for us Christian
well Wesley is completely winning
completely winning Wesley has broken
through oh it seems like Knight cd5 rook
fd8 and now B4 very important move
Bishop to f8 Knight to B6 I managed to
plant this Knight here what are you
going to do next B8 is the most natural
and what about C5 I have complete
control over the position over Black's
position right now especially on the
queen side there is no counter chances
Brewing on this side after A5 I'm just
simply going to go A3 or even develop my
piece with the tempo with a move Bishop
to C4 and after that play the move A3
there's no way you can bring back The
Rook on the a file problematic
yes
yes check King moves sure eight three
takes takes yes now according to to my
puzzle Rush yes knowledge moves like oh
how do I get my Bishop to A3 and check
me
good luck with that good luck all I
gotta do is play B6 you can jump over
both of my pawns
that's Christian turila chaos chess
could I just play Knight D7
I don't think you're in time so I take
take Knight to G4 you still have huge
problems and Knight G4 is not the only
move but let's say Knight G4 my goodness
92 no and yes he was about 96 for
walking you to play B5 and then Bishop
takes C5 and Bishop basically you're
right assistant
no it's really hard B4 and C5 that's a a
strange way of defending the king it's a
nice complex yeah yeah yeah wow yeah no
Wesley right now the only idea that I
see is actually what he played in the
game Rook to A7 keep the Rook on the A5
yes right following the
trends seven yes exactly absolutely and
let's take a look at what's happening in
this one so A5 by Bishop C4 let's say
King to h8 right right I'm trying I will
still go with the same A3 and right now
I'm actually taking back
still with a pawn wow yeah I'll actually
let you give me a check and your check
doesn't do much yeah because now The
Rook is protected yes oh yes yes it's
okay yes you're fine once I got this
bishop C40 it's very important that I
get Bishop C4 in right because I don't
want to take back with the Knight that's
going to make my pieces too passive I
want to take back with the Rook that's
going to be a pawn up and um you don't
have once again any counter chassis in
the position yeah okay very bad
and Wesley has had our defending
Champion has had the strangest
tournament we talked about Megan having
this roller coaster right it's not been
the case I think much like
um
uh Lavon Lavon came in and he expressed
a sentiment I think I can really accept
he's played too much yes out of energy
and his his energy levels I want to say
have not been his normal standard Wesley
died for nine places is it the place
where Wesley what was the last time he
died for the ninth place right exactly
exactly you have to remember very very
very uh awkward uh
event for him by the way I wanted to say
that Rue Yang Yang shamed us all
she came up with a very good move she
came up with a very good move after
Queen H4 she went down that whole
Primrose path and guess what a movie
didn't see something how nice wow very
nice no night H4 for you and the best
Megan could do was captures captures now
it's only we couldn't capture Knight was
hanging Bishop takes yeah and now we've
got a Tempo uh first of all so let's say
you go like this and you got here now
again you're you're taking a lot of
Pawns but at the end of the day you'll
have to admit that after Knight F3 no
attack yes on the king side like that's
that's not happening Queen B3 I'm gonna
be a piece up I'm gonna go G3 and uh and
rooying is going to be for choice not
from just the material but just from the
you know taming the initiative I love
the move Bishop to D7 that was no that's
good I mean at the moment when you can
exchange a few pieces which try to
attack your king that's a good uh
yes uh very very nice and uh I wanted to
ask in the game of we had seen it
earlier uh the Scandinavian wow for you
with Lanier what happened there by the
way for those of you who are joining us
late we already have one result in this
round 11. that was a very early draw
between Sam Shanklin and Lavon and where
is Lanier there he is Christopher what
what yeah exactly
well but it's not that yes it's that
there's a rook on B1 so you've doubled
The Rook on the seventh double The Rook
on the B5 but somehow one Rook is jumped
over the B pod to land up like what
let's check it out what's going on okay
when we left it we just we were all
applauding great brilliant move Knight
A3 Bishop E6 takes takes check well we
have to defend
maybe it's it's a temporary it is not so
temporary uh that's a tricky move by
Christopher that's coming with a check
the desirable C3 allows Bishop takes D2
check so Lanier had to
just took two Pawns
and two pounds in the ending two Bishops
right
wow okay now you have to give up at
least one point because of 95 Knight D5
you he said okay how are you gonna
defend the E7 Pawn I'm not said
Christopher I'm going to play this
position so Lanier has uh gambited upon
for the two Bishops open position by the
way and a rook on the seventh ring now
I'm suppose it all depends upon how we
assess the position after Rooks he said
I don't like this Rook hanging around
right maybe a little bit it's not
possible I guess
[Music]
Knight Ace
six
I like this position for who for white
in general because like if you have two
Bishops and open position I know that
like normally you are fine even if you
lose one pound even Pound Down you
should have uh certain chances even so
should I do it like this
with Bishop E5 or should I do it with
Rook to
I mean I've got the compensation I think
I think we're all agreed about that yes
the only question is do I have advantage
Anastasia Christian
back a few moves good questions
that was a good question yes this is the
commentators yes with Dynamic chances
good
good question well done you
you're a great understanding a Dodge uh
what's going on here uh Christian do you
I think there's definitely a light
Advantage for white light Advance light
Advantage for white so if black manages
to find the best moves in the position I
don't think he's Rook C7 actually
um the engine recommends Knight to E6
first not Rook today no no not Rook C7
okay 19 A6 again it's all about that C5
Square getting the roof off the seventh
rank in that position ah Knight to C5
yes and maybe Rook C7 if you go
something like Bishop D4 or things of
that nature but and by the way he played
it he just said Christopher is on the
board so what Bishop D4 you have to play
so what tells yeah uh actually the The
Rook is trapped
then no it's 95 and again where this
room goes maybe yeah it's like you would
like to do something like this C4 you
see I like the C4 yes idea maybe
C4 no Knight C5 Rook D1 95 I take
how is this okay this is this looks and
then I go C7 whatever you move I think
this should be good Bishop E5
this doesn't look good for you no
you can't go 85 or A6 but then I just
take and take on B6 and the game is over
I think so this does not look good so
after Knight A6 we reckon C4 is it must
be the critical that's like now and
never like you have to do something
otherwise the knights if I was coming
agreed yes you don't want to give your
Bishop on D5 right now no no no no no
you didn't suffer for that okay so let's
say the night goes for example okay at
least now The Rook can move somewhere so
if you go eight if I go A3 you want to
play Knight C5 I certainly do and now
there's no more Pawn landing on C6
that's about no you can still take and
play B5 but Knight F5 at the end
just I mean somehow after Knight C5 it
was possible A3 okay Knight C5 you could
take and play B5 but yes a takes before
it's it's not the same but it's not the
same yes because now Knight A5 maybe
yeah you you a moment ago you had the
pawn on C6 maybe going to C7 I don't
like it though exactly well we'll keep
an eye on that C4 and C4 on the board
yeah once a broadcast and we haven't
been able to say this for some time the
players have not shown great
understanding but these guys are really
really good yeah they they discover our
moves and uh you you have to you salute
yes exactly exactly uh Christian what
games of course there's some crazy stuff
in the ladies game let's do this move H4
say what
exactly say what H4 what's the point a
point seems to be Bishop to G5 next move
and tries to get some checkmates going
in the position so for example if you
play something like C6 Bishop G5 take
take and if you go Queen
wow I like this idea wow what does it
work I asked the questions
of course Bishop G5 has another idea
also so you have to get ready for Bishop
to G5 how do you do that you make space
for your Keen it seems like group 28 is
the best move in the position now Bishop
G5 doesn't work very well because you
take take and now Queen to f8 or queen
to F7 Queen to F7 works as well and once
you get here I have the bishop coming
back to G8 I go Bishop G8 and actually
you're just simply losing exactly
there's no way to get to my G8 uh Bishop
so that's like they can play Bishop C4
no The Bishop's gone
no I mean Bishop from D3 to C4 could go
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
that is a very good question that's a
problem and maybe with the queen even
sometimes with Queenie one yeah yes but
yes I thought that if Rook takes then
Bishops before and after rookie won
actually I have Bishop E6 back oh no so
I'm not going back so that you can take
on eight and take on G8 I got Bishop P6
and I'm a Pisa okay yes you could try to
put pressure but you found the best
moves guys what can I do yeah
wow you you you got that really good I
mean I'm trying I'm trying to find
Checkmate in every position wow
is trying to do also she's trying to
find a special Arbiter I'm I'm worried
we didn't analyze it it's me all right
yeah does it make oh it makes room
because we can trade Rooks no I no I
like to E8 I
we can trade Rooks but oh maybe I
shouldn't take the bishop okay
you definitely take the bishop
Bishop F7 this is problematic yeah you
cannot do this
um
but also G6
Bishop G5 is kind of canceled so
actually she created a trap brother
Jennifer actually she gives chance to
her poker opponent to make a mistake she
invites her please play me from G5 but
then you will lose you'll be trap but
what if I just take on E7 okay yeah I'm
in the recapture with the bishop
yeah we got to keep F5 protected right
and also now we attack H4 yes that's a
problem
yeah G3 no no no no no no sense yeah
like I mean you can play it but it
doesn't seem like you're going the right
direction I can go C5 it's looking good
for black I have to say I mean the more
I look at the position it doesn't seem
like White's attack is breaking through
um so begging has to start being quite
careful in the position by the way
whenever you move with this Rook you
also have to not forget about the A2
Pawn yes right the weakness still take
it yes sir
exactly wow not an easy position right
now and H4 might have been a bit too
much in the position for begging
yes we should stay with the lady section
I can check the other big game because
Irene I actually uh pretty much saved
her whole position oh yes
what happened she found this move this
last move that she just played the move
B5 a very nice break that simplifies the
position and actually allows her to
equalize ah this was the there was no
Knight B1 move it was Rook E1 and after
the trade B5 and she's thinking that
uh let's break up the team right at the
pawns on C4 and D5 make a very uh nice
impression if you capture Bishop takes
she's got her own passer
that looks it looks good and if Queen
takes him before Bishop D5 comes now or
whatever
yeah D6 defends The Rook on B very
important at first I thought well there
might be a back rank issue but no no no
no no no back ranks issues the night
defends E8 and I cannot uh just discover
the attack was Bishop D5 and that's
that's good enough so B5 good spot by
Arena and it seems like she might have
just equalized it kind of dodged a
bullet there a little bit the eye
opening was a disaster and yeah Jennifer
we talked about Talia when we left
Italia just played this move d4 takes C5
and I was saying I wanted to recapture
on C5 with a knight but I walked into it
before
issue yes Bishop takes meant that Talia
got to take the bishop and retain her
dark swear Bishop
wow that's a big move pastry look at
this nice actually A3 with a little with
an idea to play B4 okay and now C5
or what C5 I'm guessing A5 yeah can I
take she did it no it just meant that
all these small tricks like to put the
A3 and B4 exactly I thought maybe she
wants to play C5 but no I mean she just
improved her bonds right she took and
then shritha felt that something was
amiss here that if she takes with the
Knight F5 there's a lot of attackers
let's put it that way this bishop long
range uh piece is attacking Black's King
and after it moved like Knight takes
often times when the queen is offsides
something bad might happen she
recaptured with the pawn
right here actually it's a good point
this queen on A4 somehow can be
completely Outsider in this game and
look at uh Talia go okay so this move to
my eyes has ideas of Bishop takes F6
Knight takes F6 E4 E5 followed by Queen
takes D5 and if you take
and you try to do something like this
then it's a bishop versus knight in an
open position and there's problems wow
yes there are many problems there are
many many problems yeah again uh one of
those roller coaster Riders yes right I
mean but she's making a a comeback and
she could easily get on the podium with
a with the finishing uh kit yes uh in
these last three rounds okay finally the
open section and what's going on with
Hans Neiman
well this was this kind of double-edged
ending that we thought uh first of all
we thought that Alex was in trouble
because
he made this move night he was supposed
when he was supposed to force white to
waste a Tempo then Hans missed a great
opportunity with that Rook F1 and now
it's one two three four versus one two
three four five
six
and just the king comes look at the how
many bones he gave like already two yeah
but but wait a minute yeah this could be
a checkmating pattern with king take C6
and Rook B2 and your king you know those
rook and Bishops versus Rook endings how
you set up mating patterns
using your your voice your combined
forces this looks like one of those
where
um
uh Alex is going to die with a full
stomach absolutely yes yes what's going
on Christian it just shows how cruel
chess is because actually the last
mistake was King to D.A continue what he
had to do was King to see it
now I will explain the difference in
just a second okay now if you go C6
right and you go into the same line yes
there's some extra support be it square
is covered maybe not only that but I can
go Knight to E4 check you take on
scissors
geometry at night yes look at this not
only that but if you let me take home D6
is a Checkmate so if you go
Rook to B2 or something like that or B6
is a Checkmate nice that is very very
pretty okay this is really nice so after
wow the difference is that with King C8
you're pretty much more or less balanced
in a balanced position equal position
because I lost you're busted right now
black is completely busted aha so King
C8 equalish yes King d8 reasons All the
Right Moves up until this point and then
he just made the wrong decision
unbelievable that's the word to uh place
the king okay guys this Checkmate is
really yes it is yes
and now you don't have time to set up
your pieces unfortunately you can give a
check I take on C6 and then again the
plan that you are mentioning with Rook
to B2 that's problematic how do I meet
this you're not meeting that and if you
go something like King C8 right now I
even have ideas of going Bishop to B3
first followed by Bishop to E6 that D
Pawn is going to be uh very influential
in the position decisive wow wow
um Christian
on one of our breaks we were talking
about Alex Lindeman and you had
mentioned to me I it sounded like a typo
I asked you to clarify his rating is
plummeted he's he's been in the 2650
class looking to try to break into that
Elite 2700 level and then he just
dropped a basket of points what happened
no absolutely he actually lost around 60
rating points in the last couple of
months coming into this event he went
from close to 2600 25 90 Plus to a 20 5
35 right now whoa he was very kind to
his opponents yeah very generous very
nice of him but still I mean right a lot
it's just it's so difficult I mean and
we were mentioning it's so difficult to
make it as a chess professional I mean
you've been your whole career around
26.50 almost breaking through and making
it 2700 and then in a couple of months a
bad play you drop all the way 25 and
it's so easy to lose them it's so
difficult to win the rating points back
right yeah maybe also covet period could
affect some players you know they wanted
this yeah I mean
this over the board is so different we
everybody got used to playing online
almost two years in fact of online now
the players are getting back to normal
and over the board play we had asked
them as we know on the break we asked
the players what it's like to be over
the board and sometimes you just lose
connection look at him and he is
actually realizing if his King was on C8
as you prescribed he would have had 94
check and rook d8 and now he doesn't
have have that that is so painful and
that is a painful look I mean there
um again we haven't looked at it all
Christian I'd like to invite you to talk
about the game between darush Schwartz
and Sam Sauvignon because again these
two gentlemen have had a fine tournament
undefeated play between them and they're
in that chasing pack they want somebody
to stop Fabi and they want somebody to
stop Ray Robson what's going on in this
one it's a very complex position of
course you see the first thing at least
I see when I look at the position is
that pawn on deep right yeah of course
why it's hard yeah right but that could
potentially become a liability as well
if I manage to Corral it we exchanged
darker Bishops we get into an end game
and then I go this way too Bishop B1
Rook D1 and then managed to uh pick the
pawn on D3 so that could become a
liability as well and this is the game
between Rue Yang and Magnum that we have
on the board maybe something big is
happening in that one is let me just uh
bring that up is that what our producers
are trying to tell us
foreign
that was just a glitch
there's no
casting casting that no uh this is
actually the three pawns and we do think
white is now the one who's enjoying the
initiative a little bit but I was having
my story about it I know you had this
great story chatting about that
beautiful game yeah next position well
yeah okay so so but what you were saying
this is from the open rui Lopez with
this passer on D3 you were saying it's
blockaded but wait a minute it's
defended so it is what are the what's
the eval well the eval is actually just
zero zero of course whatever you do it's
zero zero of course I mean did you
expect anything else I did I was I was
dreaming
it's not a susvang per se but if you
move the Knight as white then you give
me squares as black so if you move the
Knight anywhere I'm going to be able to
jump with my knight to E5 and that's
going to be problematic if you move the
Knight as black then I'm going to be
able to jump to D4 as white so those
Knights are kind of set in stone right
now and just like facing each other
diagonally I guess
controlling the same squares right okay
so therefore those important squares
they're fixed they're kind of set in
stone fixed right now right
um it's all about those light squares
that you were highlighting uh the bishop
G6 defending the pawn on D3 the bishop
on E6 keeping the king uh more or less
tied down to that square h8 and you have
some problems on the eighth rack you
cannot allow me to jump with the Rook on
E8 in any situation your king is going
to get checkmated so it's this type of
situation that we're seeing right now in
the position with neither of the sides
having a clear plan that will uh create
some progress in the position and this
is what we're going to be seeing for the
next few moves okay all right thank you
for that I'll just take a look at the
Ray Robson game because we think it is a
kind of a an amusing position where
essentially the four Rooks we talked
about you know the The Rook stand ending
off the double Rooks on the B file well
it's kind of strange aren't they I mean
it's the v file is closed you remember
there was this um very funny moment when
Maxine was Telegraph and Fabiano were
analyzing game of Maxim where he played
Rook H7 move this famous game against
Maurice image where he actually gave his
member for 20 moves yeah remember what
he said you should not have a shame to
play this kind of move Rook H7
absolutely no shame to place exactly so
the Crooked too you know you have
similarly you have to play rookie too I
mean speaking about let's say your the
games you will remember all your life I
mean not even Maxim will remember
everybody will remember this Rook H7
maneuver oh it's unbelievable the funny
thing was that Fabi remembered moves of
that game better than Maxim that was
what impressed because Max was looking
at a smartphone to recall our and Fabi
was annoying yes you played here
who remembers better go away go away go
away so okay two reminds me somehow this
idea was Rook H7 exactly I wonder saying
hey look I'm not worse I can always make
the repetition let me play a few moves
and we've just seen King H3 Bishop F4
okay ray says look I can't improve my
position I can play for Bishop G5 and G4
but this looks to me like a three result
game everybody has their trumps yes time
for a break we're gonna see you on the
other side as stay tuned this round 11
of everything to play for exactly in
both events see you
[Music]
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spasky match examining their early lives
and careers leading up to their classic
match you can join John live on October
18th at the World Chess Hall of Fame or
watch the live stream on the World Chess
Hall of Fame YouTube channel that's
October 18th John Donaldson live more
information at stlouischessclub.org
foreign
[Music]
the University of Missouri is steeped in
Tradition the recently founded Mizzou
chess program is a partnership between
the University of Missouri and the St
Louis chess club Collegiate Jess has
been experiencing a meteoric rise at the
national level through its tradition of
Excellence Mizzou has always strived for
the best Mizzou chess is working towards
raising the bar by bringing our
institutions ethos of respect
responsibility Discovery and Excellence
to the chessboard
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and welcome back to round 11 and we have
a game between Brooks and and Wonderland
now on this on the screens yeah and the
the two players have been repeating this
is a huge game for both players Ray
Robson Trails Fabiano by half point that
being the case for a couple of rounds
but a wonder is trailing a Ray Robson by
a whole point and I wonder with the
victory
yeah well uh yeah we'll type a second in
case if he wins no exactly exactly so
they've been going back and forth and it
again it's one of those positions it's a
closed position and
um it's very hard for either player to
make a big impression this is where
they've been going back and forth with
the Rook
um and this is the current position I
wonder thinking
if I'm in a Wonder shoes and I'm looking
at this floor table
I I I press I play on yeah yeah I mean I
feel like
you know when am I going to get this
chance again I I have a a positive score
so I've been playing pretty pretty good
I've got a decent position so how am I
supposed to improve it well I'll go King
D7 but I think Knight G6 is considering
playing right now it's not the wonder
wonder has no no no no no Ray has no
choice right yeah
what well Ray can play Rook B1 right now
is a little bit weak Rook a one Bishop
takes A3 Rook a so the difference here
is that previously our King had been on
B8 so that the pawn on A7 was protected
in this case I get the three pawns but
oops I may have to give one back
yes no it doesn't work maybe on F2 the
pawn on F2 will be hanging so I don't
think he will go I mean they've already
repeated twice I think so I'm expecting
rooked way too Rook to B1 looks a bit
loose I mean it just feels like you can
go King B8 back yes I was about to say
King B8 A6 or A5 and
I I renew the threat of Bishop takes A3
right yes yes yeah and I guess this is
what he's thinking about now maybe with
the Knight on f8 I have time to go
something like Knight G5
and by the way guys I think Hans is just
about to win this game because uh let me
switch to that game Leatherman has just
uh simply collapsed right now
okay when we left it he hanza just
played the move King C5 and uh poor Alex
was realizing Rook B2 King takes C6 and
Rook B8 is a perfect checkmating net
Rook B2 check takes again the threat of
mate compels the move King D4 so he's
trying to block B file he played Knight
B5 right Bishop takes B5
and takes and now there goes C6 not only
the d-pawn and they were coming on the
eighth right now but also the a pawn so
it was I mean one you know it always
amazes me that it's never too late to
blunder yes what happens here yes Rook
H5 yes I was actually trying to
understand yeah and then suddenly like
while you're trying to promote your Pawn
well guess what I'm trying to promote my
pawn and then I can do it with chat wow
this is how you could just lose yeah I
say wow it's never too late to blunder
but King C6 on the other hand yes as
Christian was mentioning that's the
double threat Rook takes B5 and Rook B8
made
and I think it's resignation as well
yeah it's such a sad position you cannot
defend you cannot bring your pieces
actually into play like Rook if you play
like Rook H4 and let's say A6 yes then
at least you have F3 and rookie
but you're not getting the route back no
into play so Rook takes B5 you can
defend 18 C8 and D7 finishes the game
yes that's a nice finish yes and then
and immediately all the vultures will
come and see you know wait for your
resignation and uh they'll be all in
your business
um King C6 and uh Hans is uh
he seems to be he uh jumping in and out
of his seat there as he said this would
be very excited remember when he came in
in day one like he had won a game
against Christopher you and he said this
sends a message well that was the only
message received
it's been a while before we got a
message and I think we just sent us
another message a long time in coming
but he's sending us message after this
one he's going to be back on 50 yes I
think also by rating wise he's only been
losing a couple of rating points off if
he wins this one so it's not such a
disastrous tournament by any means he
was doing much worse until the last
couple of rounds and uh yeah that I
think he had a couple of Victories yes
yes I mean yeah Christopher elshon a
couple of days ago and now Alex and he
he mentioned that most likely this is
what we're going to see from him
an attempt to come back in the final
rounds because he said I have white
against alexanderon who has been
struggling in this event and in the past
couple of months as well let's not
forget he lost 60 rating points so he
knew his customers let's say we do have
a move uh Alex said I'm not ready to
throw in the towel on this game just yet
he's played the move King E8 and now the
simple King C7 with a threat D7
finishes 67 this is what he has done
king of seven so you can go D7 D7
and that's it yes I mean King is seven
maybe but but
yes okay
so Hans wins this game and he's on um 50
right now
he's back in the tournament actually two
rounds to go only but still well back of
it if Abby is still at plus four and
race dollar plus three a bit it's always
nice as you say to get back to uh 50 I
just wanted to go to the game between
Lanier and Christopher you because this
was the game where the two Bishops uh
versus the two knights and we were
looking at it we left it just at these
parts C4 and I was still trying to
figure out where is the advantage or
what was better right yeah what was
going on who had the advantage and and
I'm about to answer the question the
night before Bishop F6 Knight takes A2
said Christopher let me take another
pawn and then uh Lanier played Rook to
D7 Knight came back Rook to D6 Rook to
B8 Rook to D7 wow I want to take this
Pawn no you can't have it okay he came
back so what they're repeating
until you see the move G4 and Lanier
said no no no no no wait a minute I'm
better
uh I don't know if he's right but I was
just curious as to who who stood better
and G4 it's a signal like I'm better my
friend yeah it's a sign that I'm playing
for the win not you C5 Rook to D7 on the
board and I can understand that uh
while Lanier is very interested in
capturing this pawn and perhaps I'm
playing the move Bishop E5 as well if
I'm in Christopher's shoes I'm starting
to think look I I can't tolerate this
Rook on C7 can I yes can I uh challenge
The Rook with the move Rook C7 ice
and I think yeah by the way we do think
a draw agreed uh Ray says do you like
raise me
okay too and he impresses it with like
it's it's just four finger rookies
[Music]
in French yeah and Christian understands
why
French defense what have you got for us
Christian what's on your board well I
think Talia is getting her fourth
straight Victory wow this is the
position we have on the board Rook 85
was the last move and I can just simply
Play the movie you gotta ask the
question what about the fork this
probably just forces you to give me the
queen but this end game after Queen
takes F1 I'm also picking up the C Pawn
if the C Pawn survives that's the
difference with black right but if you
lose the C Pawn then this is just over
I'm going to create another pass Pawn on
this side probably take the A7 Pawn as
well this is pretty much game over so
Talia Talia is looking really good in
this swap let's take a look at what just
transpired in the game between beg him
and Jennifer because there's a bishop on
G5
so Bishop to E3 this was the moment
Bishop D5 Bishop E3 was played okay C6
and now c4 Bishop to E4 and Bishop to G5
asking the question and taking advantage
of the fact that you don't have this
idea of Bishop to F7 that we've seen in
the previous previously so now the
bishop cannot land back on F7 take take
Queen F7 amazing or G6 you lose right
right yes you get checkmated if you go
G6 yourself unfortunately you don't have
the opportunity to take only one first
so now I just picked the Rook on E7 at
the end of it right wow so Bishop to G5
pretty much forces just to play this
move Queen F7 and The Rook is not
hanging because you can take on F7 yes
you can and you take with them yeah so
you can don't have time to win
uh Bishops of opposite color I take on
G5 that is that is probably the better
move in the position and then
um C5 is an option as well in the
position Bishop C2 is an option be
careful because
yes
there's an exchange but you do have
Bishop B4 which is a very nice
intermezzo
and I cannot go and attack your Bishop
because of Bishop to City this is cute
so this is very nice geometry that right
now surely uh Jennifer seems to be
thinking about and she's pretty much
forced to go for because she's not going
to take on G5 she sees that after taking
on G5 she might be in trouble Queen F7
seems like uh the most Natural Choice
you can also go [ __ ] page two but I
don't think any human being is ever
going to play the move Bishop to H2 it
makes no sense
well to get out of Dodge with Queen D6
uh and then just simply take on uh yes
Queen D6 uh you go let's say King G1 now
I take on G5 first on G5
yes first on G5
um but it does seem like yeah
it looks yeah Bishop H2 doesn't make too
much sense to my eyes okay yes queen of
seven and queen F7 makes the most sense
on another note I think elshon is indeed
trouble against Wesley so uh Wesley been
nursing that extra Pawn Advantage coming
really out of the opening for a while
yeah now unfortunately Black's pieces
especially the Rook on A6 really is in
bad shape and I can imagine that Wesley
could just cement everything on the
queen side kind of just freezes all of
Black's pieces and again especially the
Rook on the A6 is looking for Lauren
um but anyways I read up better whoa
whoa whoa many moves have been played
pardon me since it's really impossible
after B5 at least I think she was
already doing well I still think uh
Wesley's doing very well so I just
wanted to say yes no that Arena has it
is better
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
happened so we left it after B5 yes and
as you said wait a minute I'm not going
to take on B5 and trade
I'm gonna play F4 Queen
Knight what is going on suddenly here
okay wait I see Queen the five three six
it's not a big threat so we all
understand the idea of the Discover
check yes so very very painful uh no so
no rookie eight but I'm looking From
naji's perspective she's trying
to well what's home with the pawn a D6
D7 and coronation right so what
I don't know we can maybe before
let's have a look right D6 takes
takes B3 right yes if you push the sun
just simply be told whoa whoa whoa I
think
do we know each other not maybe not so
well but I take yours King H7 you take
on bid yes okay
and everything this was checked
everything happened with the check
that's a Pity yeah
so I just I I tricked you
so easily that's I was so obsessed with
the idea
me too I understood my phone okay so
what else we have to prevent house
[Laughter]
uh I I mean I do have this threat yes
it's pretty clear I have the threat
something that I wear to play I mean I
don't want to play Rook d8 in order to
step away from beef oil but yeah okay
for example Queen is the same right and
again
we did yeah but now it's Check Yes
clever yes now I have it first so maybe
you do step away with okay but you are
not obliged to play Queen it but I'm
threatening to take on G7 yes correct
okay maybe as well as play B2 and uh
that might just wow it got sharp it got
sharp but uh probably it's still
somewhere drying
um Sam savion's game uh you've got
behind you Christian Darius seems to
have just simply blundered what and this
one and right now I think he's
completely losing oh my God this out
Rook takes F5 now you probably have to
take with a rook on E5 now if we
exchange these pawns then this is just
going to be an equal end game right
absolutely no problems he took with the
F Pawn but this opens the possibility of
check which he did you don't have to
take on E5 King to G1 is on the board
okay and right now Sam is thinking and
if he sees Rook to F3 with a simple idea
of root to G3 and you're gonna get
checkmated so for example if you try to
run away with a pawn check and by the
way I think F3 on the board it's on the
board right now and after King to H2
Queen to F3 you get checkmated there's
no way E7 and then it's a Checkmate yes
this is over you cannot use I take and
then D2 and this is the tournament
because uh it basically says Sam
savion's in third place yes yeah exactly
yeah and one point away from Fabi with
two games to go so so Fabi right now
coming into the game was a half a point
ahead of Ray Ray made her draw Sam if he
wins yeah if he wins the distance yes he
will be on clear third yes yeah at this
moment Rook F3 and what did darush do I
mean it looked when we left it yeah King
H2
right okay so I'm just seeing how we got
to this Rook takes after this was a nice
move by the way
so what he could have taken with the
Rook of course but but take it all the
way until the end where we are right now
if you go King H2 okay you know what
White's problem is
at the moment you push your Pawn then
it's queen queen 56 yes okay you move
the queen I go D2 you move the Rook I go
Queen to C5 you that about to tell me I
just go C6 you're in Sousa
uh the entirely Tom is doing backflips
over here in the truck I mean I mean he
just like I love it I love it wow
this one right now oh my God so King H2
okay this is really impressive actually
this is so many pieces of the board you
get in this position oh my God we were
talking thanks to our audience I had
asked the question what are our favorite
tactics were yeah right now yes how I
told this smothered yes with the queen
of the night it was my favorite tactic
and you were talking about your favorite
tactics but for me an epiphany was also
zuke's one like when you learned this
concept that you're compelled to make a
bad move like you're in zukon yes your
position's perfectly fine yeah
you've got to make when when did you
learn the concept of zoo
I think we normally start from the index
right so you learn it pretty fast so
when you were in the Ukraine and you
were taught the ending the endings yes
the normally even people they start from
the endings there you know wonderful and
uh Christian we're gonna jump to you
because we have guest in studio we're
doing this we are with a very happy
Victor of today's round Hans welcome
back to the studio another victory for
you and you are pre-faced it you said
that yeah in the last three rounds I'm
going to find this Ramon Tada let's just
put it that way how do you feel right
now
oh it's yeah it was a pretty good game I
was impressed that he knew like
everything 20 moves and I it's actually
funny that uh I wasn't sure if he knew
that I had a game here with black in the
world of rapid and Blitz against David
Anton I had a I can show you where it
went off sure after B4
I think I played A6 yes and uh so you
were yeah you can see it in this one and
already it's like yeah it's a big
Advantage already so I had I had
analyzed that after this game and I was
like you just knew it all I was not too
happy at least in this moment yeah yeah
so this is the mistake yeah this is what
I so yeah another Faith he mentioned
this after the game I I remember there
are some very weird ways to to equalize
this and yeah this is just a completely
ridiculous like um not a faith I guess
what did you know about this position I
knew it was equal because I had as you
saw I played it so I analyzed this a bit
from the black side and I when he played
um Bishop G4 I was like why didn't I
check this like like if you go back
Bishop G4 all the way yeah like when you
play Bishop G4 I'm like oh my God like
how stupid am I like uh he's he's been
going for let's say he's been playing a
lot of her game you know against Ray he
played sort of Knight C3 E6 94 Bishop G6
so I probably should have expected some
surprise in this love
um and I had some recent games here so
he could probably reasonably predict
what I would do but then I was like okay
well I remember this game that I played
I remember it's just incredibly
difficult so it turned out that he
didn't find this last Knight of faith
move
um yeah so but he was blitzing out by
the way at this point he had one hour
and 34. yeah but I think it's very easy
to mix these things
um so yeah F3 now I didn't know it but
it has to be the best move no he started
thinking yes and that's usually yeah
yeah it's sort of uh and also whenever
you Blitz out 20 moves of theory it
actually
um there's this sort of like inertia
effect where you feel like you keep
moving I've fallen victim to this myself
but sometimes when you Blitz out a lot
and then you mix it it can go really
badly because
when you don't realize you're in trouble
that's the worst type because you don't
you need you don't you're not as alert
so he probably was like okay
everything's okay and then yeah take a
phone I was very happy with this yep
96 yes okay this was very nice wow
okay Rook ff1
oh that is that is that is very smart
yeah just to get away from well just 97
H5 yeah or Bishop F7 oh yeah bishopstone
as well wow that is a nice little
prophylaxis I guess I need to go back to
the readings uh you know the Soviet
schools yeah yeah oh it's a DirecTV more
like prophylactic I think kramnik would
maybe would find this move like that you
know so I guess I have to I I started
reading his biography it's quite good so
I think if I finish that I would have
definitely found it so I promise
background yeah it's very good um but I
haven't finished it so
that that's that's my fault um but yeah
97 okay Rick H3 uh rookie I take yeah
okay let's go back yeah you should play
rookie fate I pointed this out yeah I
just thought he just has to be active
and again at Bishop F7 here he can just
play Rook f8 and take Knight D5 Neta
four and it's the exact same concept in
the game uh after King takes E8
I cannot play
um
I can't play Rook eat no I can't play
Rook E3 or rookie three also no King D7
is no wait where was it oh no sorry
sorry it is um uh instead of after A4
sorry after A4 yeah now King U7 I can't
for Bishop of seven because Rooker fit
and then take that defend them yeah this
is this tactic
um but anyways just to interrupt you for
a second Wesley so did win his uh game
against elshon yeah let's keep going
yeah so um this was very interesting
yeah I thought I had pressure yep yes
okay King before I really like this move
um I felt like uh
well there's an idea to play take King
A5 King A6
yeah so this is so it's actually quite
interesting so what I was calculating
was let's say um he plays net of four
here as he as he did King H2 and let's
say rookie eight then I then I would
play then I can play them over uh PC
can't play King takes and then and then
King A5 oh my God yeah the engine's now
agreeing with me amazing before it
wasn't ring but now it's agreeing yeah
and then I thought this was incredibly
difficult because let's say Rook um uh
is even Rook B2 here right as a
possibility distance makes sense but
also Rook D2 yes and I was looking at
this and I thought this was also
incredibly incredibly complex and uh we
we played a game uh
um uh
um in the summer no spring chest classic
and it was a very
it was a long end game so I felt you
know that this was like I felt like I
just need to like force him to calculate
and I thought that he would collapse so
it feels you know Alex quite Yeah we
actually uh he was actually one of the
first Grandmasters that I beat
um and not a feederated game but in a
G25 at the Marshall chess club I was
like 2250 and his USF like 27 20 at the
time yeah and I beat him on the black
side of this like you know London King's
Indian setup and I was very proud of
that cam
so yeah I've been playing Alex so
what do you feel his weaknesses are well
I've noticed just when it comes to in
this specific tournament there were just
the critical moments he was just making
a lot of blunders and when a lot of
pressure was just was put
um the reviews collapsing at times so if
you look at I think his loss against
Fabi he played G8 yeah King G8 and then
who else did he lose to he lost to um
he's been very solid but maybe he's only
lost one game no no I'm pretty he's lost
two games he's minus one yeah yeah who
else did he lose to I don't remember he
let no who was it it was was it a Wonder
yes it was a wonder and uh and he was
also the end game slight pressure and
the collapse came so I I felt the
psychologically was a very good choice
and
um you know I wanted were you worried
that he put on the board 20 moves of
theory and he most likely will not get
it well I don't I don't think it was
that yeah the time trouble I would have
definitely liked um but I felt that in
this specific end game especially I
forget F3 I was like okay I'm gonna
grind him down for for five hours here
and um eventually he should crack and
then okay in the game yes so let's look
okay let's go back this is already yeah
yeah but there are some really
interesting yeah okay so yeah take
Bishop takes yeah Bishop A4 to sort of
stop it so these five take critical
moment yes yes King C8 what was the plan
here I wasn't I wasn't quite sure I was
like I was sort of I felt to me that
King theater King B8 was natural but
um yeah okay I can see Rick H1 is is an
interesting idea but I thought C6 no no
it makes sense but but I thought let's
say C6 sure
um
yes but I thought um let's say Bishop C6
um
uh Knight E4 is the only move yeah and
uh
this also didn't feel that simple to me
like take take King C5 I wasn't sure how
to evaluate this King D7
but then I guess yeah yeah ah okay okay
so maybe I'm just stupid yeah I guess
King state is just important but again
you know I was
when I got C5 D6 I could feel the
momentum swinging you know and he played
King the eight yeah C6 yeah okay okay so
it was Kings if I have a mistake no no
okay because I'm curious here so there's
94 King C6 and G5 and now we're some
very interesting lines so yeah Rook B2
the point is Knight takes D6 okay and uh
okay ah so yes I was I was correct yes
so take and then not King B7 and this is
very weird because I was thinking yeah
King E7
no no can you save it and take take
this and and and uh take and then here I
wasn't sure oh my oh my gosh
okay I would have found it if I reached
this if I if I was forced to go down
this I'm sure I would have found it
because I was going down okay here I was
calculating King B7 yes but then I
realized that um there's King D6
and if you take like just King C7 yeah
and then you sort of shut that down yeah
but yeah Bishop B5 is crazy it's crazy
from a distance but when you're forced
to see it there's not really like an
alternative right yeah absolutely I
think uh sorry uh Hans we just last year
Mike we're gonna come back to you and I
was gonna say that Lanier is actually
doing pretty good against uh Christopher
you but let's jump back into the studio
with Hans all right uh that Bishop B5
move guys by the way that's just that's
outrageous that's great yeah I I don't
think it's that difficult to find if
you've forced yourself to find it um
because you just have nothing else um
but let's because unfortunately on this
path um but there's also another moment
here I was if you go back there's
instead of G5 there's Rook H6 as well
instead of uh G5 Rook H6 but I have the
point it was now be too thick and then I
go Rick D2 yes this is and then the
point is now if if uh G5 then I can just
take on G5 yeah and if it goes work H4
uh no no I mean instead of G5 uh then I
Then I then I have a take on T6 and then
I have um Bishop two King seven Bishop
D1
um oh no no there's actually four wait
no oh sorry sorry yes it should be three
yeah
and then I thought that I'm sort of as
long as I don't lose this Pawn
but you probably don't I probably
shouldn't yeah
that's that's very clean that's very
clean yeah I was sort of worried about
this stuff but uh yeah this bishop B5 is
definitely the killer because that was
where I felt was the most critical and
then after that it was just it was just
a dead lost I guess Hans fifty percent
with two rounds to go how do you assess
your uh performance so far it's terrible
it's just ridiculous
one of my uh three loss of three wins
yes
yes that's just
lots of decisions though no it's very
bad um and especially the fact that my
three games are lost I should have never
lost like there was it's not like uh
these guys were completely outplaying me
brilliantly it's was that uh I was just
handing them uh the win so a lot to
learn but uh considering the fact that
I've won three games I'm optimistic for
my future guys
very good uh I'll look forward to uh the
last two rounds good uh luck uh in those
rounds uh just looking at the games
between Fabi and Jeffrey this looks like
a double Rook ending uh Anastasia where
draw is literally inevitable so Ray
Robson you know with the white pieces
maybe he he had was harboring something
he didn't lose anything but it's all
about that Sam sevillion game at the
moment or are you Sam
King H2 C7 C6 this one is one of the
most peculiar Zoo twangs you're about to
see with the major piece ending but
Queen G2 why did it take him so long to
find this move uh Christian again There
Is No Escape you're you're completely
losing right now D2 Queen G2 I go D2
okay I have to move the room I go Queen
E4 oh my God between E4 with the idea if
you take on G2 Queen A1 that's coming
yes and he's going for it
and let me take another takes C5 yeah
yes I go back or
now I think about Queen D3 He played
okay Queen D3 that wins also yes with
the same idea more or less same right
well he's looking after Rook D1 Queen D3
he's looking at Rook H3 uh yes
everything
so what I have to take I mean this is
not that I can't live with this Pawn on
my doorstep and he's done it Rook takes
D2 and we need to recheck we anticipate
well the crazy part is taking on yeah
Queen E3 check why not okay each one oh
no no I can't believe it
I have to go actually King H2 no choice
so Queen takes check here check here
another one
you take many bones [ __ ] as simple as
that at some point F4 check I don't need
to take you on E5 I'm sorry Queen E3
check and oh right here this is the
position yes queen of Fortune what about
King Juan know
and now there are no other I would
probably take this Pawn away from the
board first but you understand me yeah I
understand G3 yes and if you don't play
King James yes
very very simple that's it we need three
check
and there's no escape with this Victory
very very important Victory uh Ray will
feel the heat behind him yes sam7 will
come really close
jumps into clear third depending on the
other outcomes Lanier still has a chance
potentially of joining Sam at a tie for
third King it has calculated everything
look at him go and darush knows it's too
late uh over to you Christian we have
special guests in studio we do uh have a
Wonder Liang after a crazy French game I
wonder I was bashing the French but you
decided to go with it how would you come
up with that idea yeah it's probably
like the riskiest opening I've played
this event
um what about the Petrov with Knight
takes C4 no the French is worse but
um
but yeah I just wanted
um
to sort of stray away from what I've
played before in this event
um because Rey's
kind of an expert in the Berlin and all
these e45 lines
um so yeah I thought definitely it
surprised him a little bit and yeah I
think we kind of just got a regular
position I I feel he's probably trying
to avoid some of my preparation and yeah
for the most part he kind of succeeded
but I was pretty happy with my position
in in this game at least and you were
also up on time quite a lot one hour and
29 minutes and he was dropping down to
his last 40 minutes at this point yeah I
think he he probably was just trying to
remember
um what his preparation was and yeah he
told me after the game he was
calculating I think B3 here after rookie
one which
yeah no I think um on the previous move
um instead of uh instead of recording
yeah sorry B3 or B4 yeah then takes
takes
and
like Bishop A4 Knight A5
and Bishop takes D1 Rook B6
and he has this
um after like we take everything he has
this Knight G5 at the end
um
yeah which like I missed because okay I
was just walking around I wasn't
actually sure what he was thinking about
but normally in these types of positions
like
it's kind of hard to mess up the Mover
as black I mean you can play like H6
Queen C7 97 in almost any order
um so I was like from my perspective I
was not too concerned about comfortable
obviously there was like some hidden
dangers in this position
um but yeah I think he probably was just
trying to
yeah sometimes it can be a little
confusing these lines and this was quite
funny because you started with this
Knight's position yes and then like
seven moves later you're in the same
nice position yeah yeah he definitely
missed this Knight G6 and H5 which was
just very powerful
um and yeah I thought yeah it was
definitely very funny that he sort of
just read his Knights went in a circle
um
but
but yeah I mean it was kind of difficult
for me to find a way to exploit sort of
his waste of time and sort of the issue
is like his position is still
structurally very solid like okay he
um he has like a lot of weaknesses but
um it's such a close position that I
thought he can probably just build a
fortress
um and I think in the game probably I
could have just kept the Queens on maybe
instead of Queen takes
um I should play Bishop takes
and then like Queen D2 Queen d8
um Knight G5 Bishop takes
um he has to take HG
and then
yeah but like it's it's a little
difficult to see like how I'm gonna
press here I thought like probably I
have to play like B5 A5 at some point
and then bring the Knight to C6
um weak as well yeah and also like I
thought he can just reroute his Bishop
to D2 and just kind of build a fortress
like that
um it's
yeah I mean I have like all the time in
the world but also like it's it's such a
closed position that it's hard hard to
really make progress
um yeah and in the game like okay I
thought this was a very impressive
um but but yeah I sort of realized like
okay there's not that much to do after
this
um and yeah I was kind of worried that
I'd probably blender something later in
the game so okay I thought like let's
just end it make a draw I wonder a good
event for you so far how do you assess
your performance yeah I think it's been
more or less normal
um I had sort of a crazy first half with
three decisive games and then okay now
I've made like six draws in a row so
um yeah more or less coming down
um
yeah I think I've played very solid I
sort of went into this event with kind
of a plan about how I wanted to approach
um certain games and I think for the
most part um it's been pretty successful
there's been some games where
I've sort of wanted to stay more solid
as white
and I unexpectedly got some chances like
against shankland I think I had
um sort of this incredible chance in the
opening but that was one game where I
had like work to do in the evening so I
just had to make a quick draw so now
like okay there's been some
sort of issues I think but for the most
part it's been
kind of according to plan and yeah I've
been pretty happy with how it's gone I
wonder we'll be seeing you in the next
two rounds hopefully yes
uh yeah congratulations I wonder it's
been a very nice tournament for you and
uh undefeated uh good luck in the
remaining two rounds our Championship
rounds coming up the penultimate round
as well as
and Sam sevion has one and darush yeah
darush with the white pieces undefeated
kind of that was a collapse yeah he
really did he added a very decent
position for Sam my goodness what a
stunner that was uh by the way let's
just jump to the ladies section for just
a moment I want to check in with
Jennifer and see what happened uh we saw
this kind of stunning move Bishop G5
when we left and it was a little like
there were pieces hanging everywhere
what happened queen of seven yes
and there was a trade and they went down
that Bishops of opposite color but
Jennifer threw in the very important
Tempo movie ship on this bishop before
because it's important C5 was the threat
and Bishop B3 precisely so Bishop before
and then Ruby one was not possible
because of Bishop C3 yeah so that's an
awkward way of getting your Rook trapped
in the corner isn't it I mean you just
might feel like such an idiot and uh
when those types of things happen but
Bishop before Rook
e661 okay what are we gonna do we're
gonna defend our Bishop D5 okay and at
the end of the day after all of the
back to and throwing and what have you
black
has a pawn I mean it's so hard in these
Bishops yes dollars to do anything I
wouldn't be surprised if we were to see
a repetition but then again seeing what
kind of lady players we have in this
event I mean they they don't make draws
no we have to be here through our dinner
Jennifer it has six minutes on her clock
or five minutes and Counting right now
that's two minutes for back him still
plenty of moves to go and she's a pawn
up I think she's going to try to to
press this okay fair enough by the way
so no results in any of the ladies games
no we have like four or five results in
the men's game right or the open section
they're almost done it's like only two
games are left Bobby Jeffrey we expect
to be a draw linear they're still
playing yes
we have three wins three the size of
defeated Alex Slenderman and Wesley so
managed to win today against election
um
well well well done well done jumping to
the Roo Yang Yang game because we had so
much uh interest in that one and things
have absolutely clarified tremendously
white is doing fantastic she has a
bishop for three pawns or a night three
for three pawns but much more
importantly she has the initiative and
the pawns simply haven't moved Megan in
trouble and we're going to catch up guys
guys yes
winning right now but let's see because
the position was really over sharp and
her bones were running as well as white
before we jump to the I just want to say
Rook takes H7 looks like it just wins
for yuru Yang Yan at the moment Rook
takes what else Bishop takes uh Bishop
takes okay Bishop takes F7 was a check
with a check and that's all she wrote I
have a queen for a rook at this point so
I'm expecting Rook takes H7 let's jump
to the arena Crush game it's winning did
you see it it's completely showering
right now what just happened when we
left it we were here yes
before the movie discussed with you yes
24 years and then she then Naji moved we
somehow we were expecting D6 in many of
the okay she went Rook Rook Queen okay
well made in one yes
to 6 going F6 on e4 Rook E4
and now I go Queen E8 I'm trying to
Checkmate you okay yes just Queen it and
yeah
reminding me that uh
two can play at this game
yes wow does that force me to go back
yeah it would be one maybe now just okay
two maybe even Rook to D4 I don't know
well you could even pick up this Pawn if
you want yeah and that probably is
completely winning right I'm sure it is
I mean I want to play Queen E4 or queen
E3 okay let's check of course I want to
play Queen series check because if I do
it without chicken I get get checkmate
also also and the truth is it does make
a lot of sense to even go rookie one
just from a practicality Point okay
exchange the Rooks and take the pawn on
D5 and then promote the C Pawn one of
the C pawns you have two that's that's a
very encouraging sign yeah I like your
milk rookie too in fact I like both I I
personally would have gone
I like this one only because I I know
that these double pawns are in fact well
probably that most loses maybe even
Queen F5 yeah
but yeah exactly that move loses for
another reason but same here yes if you
can exchange Queens
yeah that's winning yes that that that's
beautiful well for arena why wow she
came in a half a point behind we thought
she was losing during the year yes yeah
opening up the door for Talia and Megan
and others but no
whoa uh what on Earth did nausea Miss I
mean she could have got to this position
fair enough
and
not playing D6 is one thing but playing
Rook B1
yes maybe it's just there are some
threads and what on Earth could it be
but quite the turnaround as we have
another guest in studio uh Christian
back over to you we are with uh Sam
sevillan Sam a big victory for you
especially with the black pieces against
such a powerful opponent tell us about
this game yeah uh well he went to open
Spanish again and I'd be probably
prepared something in the light I've
been playing in this term with F5 so I
decided to play this other line which he
may not uh which one is the line a
castle Bishop C2 F5 Castle Bishop C2 F5
the one that you played against linear
yeah
uh yeah so I decided to play a different
line of course he knew it very well as
well but it's a different type of
position and you guys were blitzing out
your moves at this point one hour 35 for
him one hour 32 foreign I guess he
checked this very deeply as well he did
and right now he started thinking a
little bit
were you happy seeing that situation
develop uh yeah look after Bishop A2 yes
okay I think he started thinking here
yes
uh yeah well I mean if you don't play E6
then
um there's not really any other ideas in
the position so rookie six A6 E6 28 yeah
and this was still your preparation yeah
well he played B4 and then E6 which is
the same right yeah got it so he played
B4 okay four E6 Queen d8
by the way I think the engines were
actually agreeing with you at this point
David speaks the first movie I didn't
know
um but I think take six is fine
so we were looking at the position and
it felt completely crazy right yeah yeah
tell us about the strategical and
tactical motives well the position right
now he has hanging pieces on the f file
you could have avoided this by moving
the bishop somewhere the G3 or D2
instead of Bishop B6 which would be a
safer alternative Bishop D2 yeah yeah or
Bishop G3
um but what he did is he was trying to
concretely
take advantage of the fact that my
knight on C6 is hanging with this queen
A2 idea and the point is if I take it I
was looking at this for a very long time
yeah take take D2 let's say Rook D1
queen f8 king G2 H5 and now he has Rook
62 H6 G4 and Knight E5 and family for
coming
[Music]
yeah this one is not looking here yeah
yeah so then I saw that I can play
Bishop G6 uh Queen D2 it's only move and
here kind of very important moment I'm
really happy about this H6 because if I
go Bishop D6 which is very natural he
goes Bishop G5
and my pieces are extremely awkward I'm
not sure how to play them so yeah chick
is a very important move absolutely uh
here he has many candidates but I think
he should play Bishop B3 with the idea
of meeting Bishop D6 with takes in
rookie six there you go okay so I would
probably play Bishop back to H7 when I
mean Black's completely fine here
because I have a good counter play on
that file I like Black's position you
like Black's position yeah
uh he went King G2 I think he missed
Bishop D6 uh instead of Bishop takes D6
very important line it's Bishop takes H6
Rook takes F3 King takes F3 Bitcoin H oh
I didn't see Queen
id4 is coming yeah this is even stronger
that's very nice
very very nice
yeah he has to take on he has to take it
take and he went for the concrete line
which is net H4 Bishop H7 Knight F5 I
take take net E5 F4 Rook takes you off
and I think I understand what he missed
uh but that's because rookie five
obviously definitely has to play rookie
five yeah yeah I would play Rook fate
and then he was down to 10 minutes it's
already very unpleasant because I'm
threatening G5 here
yes just came over yeah and to play H4
in this position weaken your kingmore is
so difficult
yes yeah so he took on E5 with the F
Pawn of course I was extremely happy to
see this you understood that at this
point you're just breaking through yeah
yeah I think what he missed was that
after Queen D5
uh King G1
probably King H2 here probably changed
two and I just said King G8 yeah and
here
H for Queen C4 and everything's falling
and if E6 of course there's Queen D6
check which is the points yeah and the
game is over very nice yeah
I mean that's an important victory for
you uh Sam to keep your hopes alive to
win the championship yeah for sure
you're definitely still thinking about
that what do you need to do to catch up
with the leaders oh well I mean I have
two important games left with Hans and
Wesley so I think I need to get some
good rest and sleep well tonight
absolutely right out the energy levels
are definitely playing a major role guys
any questions no just our
congratulations uh well done Sam and get
your rest and we'll see you in the
penultimate rounds tomorrow uh turning
our attention we have a Victor Talia
that is
amazingly hot
four wins in a row Alejandro will be
very happy very happy that's the way we
like it I'm turning my attention to the
game of Alice Lee my apologies to Alice
Lee's fans but they will be very pleased
to know that the 13 year old Alice Lee
looks like she's in a winning position
she's an exchangea against a tatv so wow
big result Arena Crush
um trying her best to catch up with
Jennifer you she did Arena did not go
for that line we thought we thought the
simplest was to play Rook takes E4 yes
exactly
B7 and queen E8 we thought that yeah we
thought that would it would do the trick
Bishop C8 Bishops
um
C2 Rook E2 Bishop A4 Bishop F5 on the
board well I must say it's still looking
very good but
okay there
I like Simplicity yeah this is now there
is no Queen yet Bishop only foreign
and for the moment this this queen is on
a like an oh I was about to say awkward
diagonal but maybe that move Queen G7
just clears everything I mean because
again the seat Pawn is coming so for
example takes takes I suppose this is
going to be better for well winning for
for black so maybe Queen G7 and Arena's
got everything under control as well
Anastasia where would you like to take
me seems like there's a big moment right
now in bagim's game yes let's check the
team has given perhaps after this move
wait a minute when we left it we we were
saying Jennifer no way uh she's going to
make sure yes yes okay after Bishop
rugby won she played King f8 we could
expect Jennifer yeah
Bishop back Rook to d one
okay
offering a trade
no says begum no trade for you okay
let's trade Rooks then no no trade for
you 84. I see
geometry yeah
yes right let's let's put that on the
board because it is rather attractive
right Bishop takes A4 Rook takes D5 and
uh Bobby Fischer would say background
Checkmate is Bobby Fischer teaches chess
it's like 200 examples of back rank
Checkmate the dude was a White Wave one
second Anastasia I'm telling you
uh what happened after A4 D6 on the
board and now rookie five wasn't right
yes D6 I feel this one probably is going
to uh what what was crazy I'm sorry
after D6 Christmas yes yes rookie five
Rook E5 immediately yes correct really
okay exactly the idea uh huge pitfalls
if you take you're losing
king of seven
oh no exactly that was a big moment oh
Jennifer missed a chance she she well
she's down on the clock yeah quickly
captured captured captured and after
King F7 she enjoys an extra Pawn but
this is a very active Rook this Rook it
not only cuts the king but it tethers
The Rook to the defense of the B7 Pawn
yes how good was that Miss uh Christian
oh my word Jennifer the position was
still equal
um maybe slightly better yeah
but you almost automatically take on A4
right yes of course yes you just played
D6 and then you take on A4 and then King
F7 you resign resign yes because the
Rook actually guessed it G6 yes and King
F6 is coming yes exactly oh my goodness
like where is the movie that's beautiful
30 seconds on her clock was Rook to E6 I
believe she was resisting very difficult
to find very very difficult to find she
was trying but
playing this position I mean it's not
easy at all with the white pieces no no
no no no
and Arena Arena's position I think she's
on yes they did that moved Queen G7 it
just clarified everything I'm
threatening to go you want check and
queen yes and that's it and this Pawn is
not going anywhere my king is in the
Square but my Bishop also patrols D7 and
if you can give one Bishop D3 comes
right yes I think
and if Irena wins and by Rue Yang Yang
broker Street
Megan
in the road yes sir can you imagine you
lead the tournament and then you lose
three games in a row it's such a cruel I
mean unbelievable heartbreaking yes yes
but guys if Irina wins which she is
Jenny for you
tomorrow yes yes oh that's how Hollywood
script
the final rounds I mean it's always like
that it feels like I know I know it's
crazy isn't it of course of course of
course we ask them to make this results
to make sure that it's going to be a big
drama I'm just about to give a Checkmate
right no I think Sabina is just about to
give you the checkmate
this is what we'll be looking forward to
everything on the line between and again
Anastasia I'm looking at this and I'm
I'm saying if our producers lost their
minds because I would have lost uh about
some money yesterday
they played three classical games Rina
and Jennifer together played three
is just about to finish there's going to
be a Checkmate in that one maybe we can
catch it which game or a handshake
Sabina versus Sophie Sabina Sophie Yes
actually yes
and there it is we were just a second
too late but Sabina delivered the
Checkmate delivered the Checkmate
Checkmate is on the board not so often
it doesn't happen so often and this is
between Sophia Morris and Sabina a game
we're looking at is Arena and Naji but
Queen I mean okay Sabina chased this
King group
look at this there it is nice
well done okay yes so by the way yeah
for a moment that there was no results
yes now suddenly everybody finished and
there's been three victories of the
three uh results that we've had and uh
two of them by white that Sabina wins
with the black pieces we expect Alice
Lee also to win against as well and I
thought that was going to open up the
door but Arena's win uh doesn't give
Alice much much room yeah let's just see
we've got this position
okay well wait a minute did she have to
get to allow this okay
but uh we have a guess Christian over to
you Talia for uh wins in the last four
games you're really making a run for it
how do you feel right now I feel great
um
even though we had the rest day
yesterday and it looked like
look like my momentum I'm quite happy
with the game from today so hopefully
just
um goes well for me until the end of the
tournament were you concerned about
losing the momentum uh due to the rest
day or I was a little bit but I was more
busy
um either trying to catch up with school
work or trying to meet some friends so I
think maybe it was nice that I did get
distracted absolutely take us through
the game because it felt like quite a
smooth uh game by you right did you get
the preparation that you wanted over
exactly maybe you can
deduce that based on the amount of time
I spent in the opening but I was pleased
with the position that I had
um I wasn't exactly sure which planet I
was going to go for and actually it
seemed it felt like the position changed
a couple of times
um because for example here I was down
to play with like F4 with D4 yeah with
D3 and Knight D2 and Knight F3 something
like that maybe even G4 at some point
but then the the I guess the position
just kept on changing
um and then she played this bishop C5
which obviously forces me to play with
D4
um but I was I was alright with the
position that we got and I think uh
maybe a few moves later
um
right so here I felt like things started
to look up for me I wasn't exactly sure
how to evaluate the position before that
but obviously she can take on C5 with
the Knight because then there is before
um
and I thought it was just a strange
decision by her to go to KCA but now
it's not so clear right because my Pawn
on A2 is hanging right so Queen takes A2
I was considering Bishop C3 or Bishop D4
I kind of liked Bishop D4 catch this
this queen somehow right right but it
keeps on escaping like after rookie won
Queen series two and it keeps on
escaping so I thought maybe bishop D4
was more accurate since it's more
um direct and maybe I was considering
Bishop D4 something like Rook C7
um at first I was looking at Rook F2 but
I think uh she didn't just played Queen
C2 and I don't have any nice night night
jump
um so no 94 because you can take with
right or the pot yeah so probably in
sort of work up to do something else
when you feel like you're right taking
over the initiative in the game
um
I felt like when I got a3b4 in my
position was beginning to get good and
um yeah so after E4 the issue that her
pieces are very misplaced and I was very
surprised
um honestly I think I missed maybe Queen
F5 also works here I'm not sure
um
yeah it looks fine but after a rookie
Aid
um yeah I here I thought that I was
doing pretty well and I was quite
surprised when she went for Queen C4
because she did think about this move
quite a bit but
after a night of five I don't think
there is there is much hope and
especially after he took on D5 and
allowed Knight to E3 I was quite
surprised because she was thinking and
then she also went for this line so I
thought okay maybe I missed something
but there's nothing and I think after
that it's just
um a nice conversion
absolutely no problems Talia
congratulations four out of four uh
tomorrow you're facing begin you know
her quite well you've played her quite a
few times and you guys are friends as
well how is that the Rivalry going on
um we have played two times she actually
has a plus score against me last year's
championship I got lucky and made a draw
with black hopefully this time I can
just get a better game than last time
absolutely guys any questions for us
yeah absolutely first of all tell you
congratulations very very nice four in a
row I just uh just a moment of honesty
between us only uh five days ago did you
wake up and say wouldn't it be nice to
win four games in a row was that on your
mind at all did you say yeah okay now
turn on the heat
there wasn't a specific moment where I
thought that I was going to start
winning games but I had some trust that
I was gonna that it was gonna happen at
some point
um even though I lost your Arena it was
a very bad game I kind of felt like
overall my play was fine and that wins
were gonna show and I just left it in
the air with trust and actually Sally
you have now seven points at the moment
and not a clear third place maybe even
better who knows by the end of this
round what are your Ambitions in this
event right now especially considering
this tournament situation
well going into the tournament
um I mentioned I wanted to go top three
and I'm happy that I'm on track
um obviously it's very difficult I
believe before this round we're maybe
six tied for the top three spots so it's
obviously still very complex and I I'm
not sure what's gonna happen I don't
want to think about it too hard either
I'm just gonna try and focus on my game
um tomorrow and the day after but
certainly it would be amazing if I can
get top three
yeah Talia congratulations absolutely
penultimate round coming up tomorrow and
then the championship round as well uh
Jennifer again she's uh
on the nice side I want to say she's got
an extra Pawn but really I mean a draw
is almost inevitable for example if you
play F3 obviously it would be nice if
you could get in G5 but I'm just going
to put the kibosh on that idea right
away by putting my Rook on the fifth
rank because you're not going to be able
to play G4 and recapture yeah I'm never
gonna let that how about this F3 G5 yes
Rook B5 you have to try it right you
have to go G4
I have to play G4 I I feel like you have
to at least try yeah
you want me to play for the Checkmate
yes if you let's say you don't find
forget about this I just move this is
why we have to remember about the sun
this is how you can lose sometimes yeah
but sometimes you know like I can end up
losing so you don't want to try okay
okay
I can end up messing it up but maybe not
maybe not I'm giving you another chance
let's go into that I'm sorry I'm gonna
give you another chance okay take
so let's go no no no no sorry F4 King H3
rookie three yeah and now maybe you go
King H4
right now I go what after King G2 King
H4 right
I'll give you another chance Second
Chance second chances for checkmate very
very nice uh indeed unfortunately there
is rookie too yes
it's a problem I'm just worried that
there might be issues but we have guests
in studio with You Chris and we do have
G3 by the way okay begum's defending a
different way in this a little bit
suspicious to me but
maybe it's still enough to make it draw
let's see she has an idea I'll tell you
over to you Christian please thank you
uh yes sir yes we are with riyan Yen
after an important Victory riank take us
through today's game um so I don't
usually Play Bishop C4 but I prep this
sign for her
um and after Bishop C5 C3 Knight F6 D4
ed4
um E5 I prepped after takes I pressed
Bishop before Bishop to be foreign
yes so Bishop B6 was a new thing for her
did you know anything about the position
well I just knew this like and then
Bishop B3 and Knight D2 but instead of
97 oh I think she should have played
Bishop G4 and I think maybe like Bishop
B2 or I'm not sure
yeah yeah I I I just knew like you know
like Kevin Gates F3 or to go F6 things
that yeah yeah so it's important to set
up this bit on the h5d1 app and she did
not
she played uh she did but it was like a
move too late and now Bishop takes F3
doesn't you can take back with the
Knight with the Knight on D2 that makes
sense
and then you got the disposition H3
Bishop D4 yeah Bishop by four how did
you assess
I calculated like a lot of lines and
some are like really weird and like like
I think I like I said Bishop at four oh
I was calculating like Queen D3
um and then Bishop B3 it like takes
takes and then like Bishop H3 like I saw
this and I was like shouted out 25 yeah
I was actually evaluated like if I had
gone to this position I'd probably
played like Rook F5
yeah
but he wanted more yeah than that yeah
so you found this beautiful move Bishop
to F yeah because I realized her Knight
like she can't stay for night because
the only thing I was saving it was like
attacking the E3 Bishop so I moved it
very nice makes logical sense of course
uh and then he found this beautiful yeah
I thought this was really nice because
she had she I always thought I was
calculators during the game and she I
saw like she had like all like 984 ideas
like I mean I think this was probably
still okay but I didn't want it like go
into this you have to go G3 yeah this is
not yeah it's really risk I I really
like so I I think I thought this was
nice because I kind of pinned her night
and she doesn't have any like yeah
and then
towards the end I think you found a very
nice solution afterward 38 Rook takes H7
beautiful way to finish things off and
uh right now you're having a pretty
decent event how would you assess it how
would you assess your iPhone so forth I
guess the results are fine but the games
uh like my gaming is Savina like after
the game just cried for like 30 minutes
really wow
did you analyze with your coach or yeah
was your coach mean to you
yeah I didn't want to look at it
thank you very much for joining the show
we'll see you tomorrow through Yang our
congratulations we thought you played a
really really fine game and Bishop D7
especially caught our attention a draw
agreed yes between Fabi our tournament
leader and Jeffrey Zhang as Fabi
maintains he's a very very curious half
point lead with two rounds remaining
again Ray Robson half a point behind and
a half a point behind Ray is Sam said
again and maybe I'm thinking Lanier
Dominguez the soul remaining player
might catch him as well he has some
chances in his position
for a break let's just take a look at
our results start with the ladies
Anastasia women's results so how many
games have finished already three games
and all of them were decided
did
defeated Megan Lee and we can see also
that Sabina for sure managed to win
against Sophia Maurice Suzuki absolutely
very decisive battles there and in the
open and in the open I think we have
like what all results or what maybe one
game yes okay here yes the one we
mentioned layer is still playing against
Crystal for you all the other game
finished and how many three decisive
results so far exactly we have three
draws and we are going to see you on the
other side of our break
[Music]
thank you
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spasky match examining their early lives
and careers leading up to their classic
match you can join John live on October
18th at the World Chess Hall of Fame or
watch the live stream on the World Chess
Hall of Fame YouTube channel that's
October 18th John Donaldson live more
information at St louisjessclub.org
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to round 11 of US
championships and we have three results
in women's section uh Thalia one Megan
Lee lost against and then also Sabina
managed to win her game and I think
we're just gonna see another win take
place as Arena just played this really
nice visual move Rook takes G2 and she's
won her game it's a done deal uh wow
Naji I thought had had fought herself
to a defensive draw but that was not the
case I was really surprised that she
went down so quickly in this ending but
this final blow right here that was a
very nice move King E2 and there's
nothing to stop F4 F3 F2 but equally big
news is going on in the begum versus
Jennifer game as we're on break and this
move G3 was Dreadful it's a howler it's
a howler Christian howler Christian I
didn't like it of course no explain to
our viewers why she made that move one
of the easiest way out of that the easy
way to contain Black's offensive is to
just simply go Rook to B5 right because
black has only one idea is to go G5 G4
and try to put some pressure on you like
this clear you can do that you can get
away from that by playing the move Rook
to a B5 you can also play the move F3
right in the position after G5 now Rook
to B5 once again G4 doesn't work because
you take and actually you lose this
position so you have to go back now I
give you a check if you want to make any
progress you're going to have to go
forward and then I come back and if you
stay with the move Rook to F7 now I can
actually just simply lose a Tempo or
defend still defend against G4 with a
move Rook 2 B4 so there's no way you
make any progress with the black PC is
now changing the structure with the move
G3 is actually a very bad idea because
right now you have to take with the F
Pawn is the only saving move in the
position if you take with a king which
feels natural right you take with the
King you go towards the center you keep
the pawn on F2 so you have some tempies
in the tank as well it makes some sense
right so you take with the King and now
G5 this is in the position right now and
I think F4 might be the most critical
one the problem is that I go G4 so I
don't give you a check and pick up the
pawn because that doesn't make too much
sense I'm going to pick up on B7 you're
not going to win this exactly but what
I'm going to do is go G4 and now you're
in a pickle because I have a big threat
Rook to E3 Rook 2 F3 Rook to F4 right
and if I manage to get two versus one
that's going to be losing right I'm too
advanced with my points there's no way
you can uh get away from that now
what happens after Rook 2 F6 and this is
the critical uh line Rook to E3 King to
G2 let's say right and now you take
if you take on F5 I go King to H4 and
you don't have time to check me
I'm going to check you next and then I'm
going to hide my king behind your Pawn
King to G3 King to F3 G3 and that pretty
much is game over right so you're just
simply not in time as white this is
completely losing
I don't know what else you can do with
the white pieces I guess King to F3 but
now I can just like wait and try to get
on the third rank what do you do next if
you go here I'm going to go F4
if you go here now I'm going to go maybe
check maybe Rook to F7 I'm waiting and
at some point you will have to move the
king back so for example if you go Rook
to B5 King to H4 Rook to B6 G4 already
King to G2 yes and I'll Rook to D7 back
right I made some progress now I'm going
towards uh the second Rank and then
you're going to have to stop me from
playing G3 which you're not going to be
able to do and you're going to lose
you're going to get slowly squeezed so
with rock on D2 you cannot stay on the
second rank
and that opens the possibility for my
king to walk around and get to F3 right
since you cannot put the King on G2
because of this move G3 this one is not
looking good for beg him right now and
uh
she played The Rook to B5 in the
position
black has to play the move F4 so another
critical moment right now if you play
the move King to G6 it seems like this
one is actually a draw wow once again
you cannot make progress whenever you go
F4 now I jump with the King to G4 so now
I'm just waiting I'm waiting yes waiting
whenever you go F4 I go King G4 and I
make a draw so you have to go F4 first
after Rook to B5 King F3 now you have to
focus on uh getting I'm actually curious
what if you go here so okay
and now you have to go back go back
because Rook F7 Rook H6 is a big problem
so what you have to do
is uh to go Rook to F7 in the position
yeah yes
but once again this is yes G4 now yes
this is the key this is go to E4 then G3
is just winning yes
um but this is still not an easy end
game
by any means no but it is winning but
when you see that the black pawns had
started on F6 and H6 it the what have
you this is just absolutely huge by the
way we do have another result Rochelle
versus Anna zatonski that game was a
draw it looked like both both players
just played correct chess
special happened Alice is still enjoying
your extraction extra exchange uh she's
even a pawn up at the moment she's gonna
lose this pawn and I think she's just
gonna go Rook to a C5 and eventually
this king is going to Menace the H6 pawn
and there's nothing that tatv is going
to be able to do about it so I do think
Alice Lee is close to winning this game
um although it kind of slipped away
Christopher you
he ended up
giving up an exchange for one of the
Bishops and he ended up having to give
up his Queen side he's now in a terrible
predicament of Rook at night versus two
Rooks two pawns on the same side of the
board the Knight can make it awkward but
it's like one of those things that
inevitably slowly slowly slowly you get
ground down and it's a lost sign I think
so yes I think so how how do you do that
I don't know how usually usually I end
up with one Rook on the seventh and one
Rook on F5 so let's get let's say I go
King G7
okay and let's well geez I I really want
to Rook on the seventh but okay let's
say I go over here now I stay
um but that's not winning no that's okay
that should be a draw yes yes so let's
say you wait so let's say I go here
let's say you wait just give me
everything I want for just a moment and
this is what I want it I want to tie you
down whether it be your night on d8 or
your Rook on f8 ideally I think the Rook
would be the best because then I can
easily uh bring in my king and at a
certain moment I can then threaten your
knight and make a attention
right precisely precisely so so you
shouldn't allow me one Rook on the
seventh and one Rook on F5 if you can
avoid that make it difficult but
checks I don't know if they're going to
help or not but let's give you some
checks right exactly whether it be
uh hold on I'm not sure what our current
position apologies let me just refresh
my board
and here I think we were looking at King
G7 at a certain moment
but Christian you have a guest in studio
we are with the a-time national champion
Grandmaster Irina Crush after a very
important Victory Arena welcome back to
the show this was a difficult game she
was all over you after the opening did
you feel the same way yeah I mean this
was definitely I think one of my hardest
games here I mean it's actually maybe
the only game where I didn't get great
position out of the opening
um I didn't feel like it was terrible
but maybe because my lack of knowledge
of this line
um yeah so this move she played D5
um I mean I had seen that I was a
possibility I just didn't evaluate the
position of so bad for black like I see
the the edge of the computer is giving
here I definitely did not uh think it
was so bad so uh let's go let's play a
few moves and it wasn't that bad
especially if she doesn't make the very
precise moves such as A4 and things of
that nature I mean it just seemed okay
like uh like her strategy was ambitious
with D5
um but you know I have this blockading
night I have a lot of problems to solve
like the bishop on B7 is not great
um but yeah like I still felt like this
this part was okay so the thing is that
she you know I was quite uh I think I
really should thank Nazi for playing
very ambitiously in this game because it
was clear that you know she wanted to
play it safer she could have she had
many opportunities to do that and the
fact that she kept trying to beat me you
know until the end that's kind of like
what backfired right it's what gave me
some chances
um you know but yeah she she really did
try to let's keep going you're talking
about this moment when you play the move
B5 yeah I mean
I mean lots of moments like even if we
go back a little bit
when she has this choice
right like I
right of course you know she could take
an F6 and I mean I didn't think actually
again I didn't think the same game was a
problem for me I see I was probably more
optimistic about my position than the
computer
um I guess I just thought my knight on
D6 would hold everything together and
um you know I didn't appreciate this
plan A4 until a little bit later like I
did actually
um at some point in the game I was like
oh yeah she can take on D6 and just go
completely change you know Direction go
to the queen side and try to play
against the B6 pawn and the bad Bishop
on B7
um but okay yes you should have that
option
um she went to take this Knight and then
A4 and again you know I never actually
felt that I was doing so badly here
actually so maybe that was good like I
was a little
um optimistic about it yeah I mean I
thought my position was okay to at least
not lose right okay so um we keep going
and this is a tricky move Rook E1 yeah
and I played B5
so this was my first chance to really
break out with that pawn and using a
couple of tactics
um yeah like for example she could play
C takes B5 right Bishop takes D5 and you
know Bishop takes D5 Queen takes D5 and
then actually she has this rookie five
move which I kind of underestimated when
I first went for this line and okay I
mean I thought I had various yes Queen
D6 or queen D4 here
um they're even Knight C4 yeah either
Queen D1 or even Queen C7 I thought
maybe it could be doable
um yeah so I didn't think I was gonna be
losing these positions but obviously
winning was going to be uh it's not it
wasn't gonna happen right so like here
she played the move F4 which honestly I
didn't see it all I thought it was very
interesting move very ambitious
um again you know creating problems for
me in my time trouble right because I
was already getting like kind of lower
on time than her and yeah I mean this
move before of course it's very
double-edged like you can you can lose
after playing a move like that but I
mean okay that's still far away so she
Queen E5 this all of these were pretty
critical moments and I remember when she
went for like 94 yes
yes I mean none of that was obvious to
me at all like she played this move
actually pretty quickly and I just I
didn't quite get it because it seemed
like there were so many options and I
wasn't sure what she was going for
actually
um with this move like okay so I was
spending a lot of time just trying to
figure that out and I think she's giving
up a park right so yeah she's giving up
a pawn and I mean I always have this
rookie eight idea I mean I I guess that
rugby one was her point and actually you
know what I thought it was I thought
maybe she wanted to sack her Queen at
first after rookie eight uh Rook takes
B7 uh and you know because at first I
was like okay then maybe that's not so
clear but then in this position okay I
didn't see F5 to be honest that's an
interesting move I was gonna play C3
um but at least I realized he had D6 and
I can go either G I can like start with
G6 and then go Queen d8 she's not
actually going anywhere with the pawn
and so okay like I I knew I wasn't
losing in this position which I at first
I thought like maybe that's her idea
um so then but basically if she doesn't
have this then her position is just not
very good after rookie eight because
um yeah she played Queen F5 interesting
wow I was doing that wow okay well at
this point just take on e4 and queen to
E8 that was computers yeah Queen E8
which we just bought this uh idea you
know I had I had this idea somewhere but
I where is the mate am I oh am I mating
with uh rookie two and then that's what
it is yeah you know what I just didn't
see that I was actually mating I mean I
saw these ideas but yeah and
occasionally you don't even go for the
mate you actually just exchange the
Rooks yeah and take the D5 pawn and
that's just simply winning yeah well I'm
not shocked I have something here it was
really complicated because I know we
were both in time trouble in this part
um so what did I do but still what you
did did not lose the advantage by it
yeah and rookie too I mean I have to say
I like that move a lot like I felt like
this part of the game I played pretty
well because you know we were down uh
you know to the last minute on the clock
and that's basically where I won and I
was shocked you know that she had this
transition to the losing the exchange
because here I just thought I'm winning
and and then suddenly she has this uh
she has D6 and I'm like oh I'm uh I have
to give up and thankfully thankfully
this is actually still completely
winning because of the pawn yeah
probably you're still winning yeah
handily but this one is easy Arena a big
big moment for you a big game for you
because this one was difficult one and
Jennifer you seems to actually be
winning her game uh against beg him
tomorrow you face Jennifer you yeah
that's a great setup isn't it
anything better I mean if you want to
win the tournament you get to play the
person who uh who is um in contention
for first place with you and yeah I'm
very happy I mean this game it's funny
because I couldn't win all my winning
positions in this tournament right but
then suddenly you win a position that
you really weren't supposed to win right
and that's kind of like a very nice gift
um so I guess I don't know maybe that's
the key to get worse positions or get
yourself into some some uh some trouble
and then you have better chances to win
I don't know Arena we're looking forward
to uh tomorrow's game thank you in a
quick question on sasia yes uh
considering the fact that you have not
such a great score with Jennifer you so
how how does it affect your mood if it
affects oh yeah not at all I mean those
kinds of things don't really affect me
um because you know we don't have a
great score that's just always a chance
to improve things and
um
and I remember when I first started
playing Anna in our first meetings that
we're also not very successful for me at
the very beginning of our rivalry but
you know as you kept going you uh you
just have a chance to turn things around
so I definitely
um I just feel really good about about
this game winning with the black pieces
against a strong player like Nazi and um
you know I feel like okay I mean I have
chances right I'm gonna you have to
remove the obstacles yourself if you're
going to win first place obviously and
I'm you know I'm happy for this
opportunity wow that's a great attitude
something to learn here it is thank you
thank you good luck tomorrow Arena and
very good luck tomorrow as the
penultimate morale well wow
two two leaders will be facing off um
just seeing this game of Alice Lee I
think tatv uh is on the back foot but
the best move I mean she definitely
she's in one of those positions where
it's like uh do I want to give up the B
Pawn do I want to give up the H Bond I
don't want to do any but I have to move
the Bishop with this move Bishop C4 at
least in this case it makes Alice stop
if you take the pawn I get to go King C3
King takes B4 with some counter play of
my own if I have to play rookie 3 to
stop the king and then
I don't take the bomb it's still it's
still uh work to be done but this move
Bishop C4 definitely taught us best
going back to our huge game between
begum and uh Jennifer uh we catch up
with the position Rook C3 check just on
the board and I think this was the uh
the position that Jennifer is actually
shooting for if you can after King
E4 G4 you take a pawn this is where we
get
the two pawns versus the Juan pawn and
the two Pawn should actually be winning
in this position uh The Rook is just
going to be ideal sitting uh behind the
ponds and that's how Jennifer
is planning on winning the game
absolutely yes the king just moves and
helps his Pawn pawns to promote so what
after King G2 whatever
I think I'm I'm winning this Pawn by
force aren't I Jane G4
Rook takes B7 F3 check let's go King H2
ah you've got Rook G3 Rook before sorry
you've got Rook before just a second I
apologize so King G2 I have to play G4
um and I keep on taking
uh Rook here G1 threatening G3
1
how do I
there are some issues they're still
definitely and then what maybe you move
your king towards say four equals F3
looking to five and
six I want to go F3 check and Rook f
oh maybe we can go walking H for King H4
uh at the start
at the very beginning yes after King G2
King H4 uh the the current position is
check
King G2 and King H4 is a starter move
correct so the same idea but whenever
you go Rook B4 I go G4 I cover with G4
so now I go F3 F3 put the Rook on the
second rank okay Juan
and that's the difference so King can be
on oops excuse me for check Rook F1 yeah
and the King can as you say block G4
that's nice yes that's very nice you
give check from Mage file you go King G4
you hide your king exactly after room
takes G4 King takes G4 I still have my B
Pawn
ah it could be a very nice Tailwind yes
uh-huh Kristen just showed this idea
before it takes before but you have a
steal away exactly because to be part
wow wow a huge huge uh big moment right
now right four seems to be the right
solution
what about King
H4 King h4s
okay so after King to H4 yes what if I
tried
so if I go Rook to B4 now
yes yes then I guess you can just go B5
is that a move
F3 and
yeah and once again uh you can't go back
I can't go back I gotta go even King GH3
the language of Chess we've got FPS it's
our producer's favorite graphic yeah iqp
the isolated coupon the isolani
lpdo now that one no I'm not I don't
know we gotta lose pieces drop off lpdeo
I mean get out of here Dr John okay
yeah baby the check
I like this this is all good yeah
this was from dorsa I mean the shish
kebab
when you're in Iran and you're learning
the Iranian chess
very very oh wonderful so lucky it's
called in Greek yes
[Laughter]
pure nice
um wow big big moment here for Jennifer
uh one of the things I really noted the
ladies for Alice Jennifer they have come
in come into this competition with
extraordinary fighting spirit and even
when this game was heading into a
bishops of opposite color ending there
was a like we had no doubts that it's
gonna that they were gonna play a long
long long time which is exactly what's
happened and Jennifer looks like she's
going to be rewarded for her fighting
Spirit should she find the move King H4
in the current position
when she met is to outplay her in a
matter of long long fight the first
round of this Championship remember when
she brought her King first to A8 as you
suggested and started to move finally
the bone and then moved it all the way
back yeah so she showed actually also
her fighting spirit for starting from
the beginning of the tournament and here
we are
I was really thinking that Jennifer was
going to allow us to remove repetition
yeah yeah no no because she didn't find
A8 right away yes no no she was fighting
until the end and it paid her back yeah
Christian you've got the Alice Lee
position on you on your board yes this
one is just uh finishing up right now
King to C5 has been played we're
expecting uh a push over the H Pawn and
then I'm going to be able to hold on to
your b-pawn for example King to C3 I can
just simply go to H4 for example it's
the easy way out you cannot keep the
bishopone a C4 and you cannot go B4 so
for example Bishop D3 yeah
and that's your counter chance right you
have to be able to go B4 but
unfortunately you cannot without the
bishop on C4 this is her plan it makes a
lot of sense logical sense the king is
cut you're never going to be able to uh
defend against the expansion this slow
expansion of the H Pawn this one is
exactly you thought that the game
between Lanier and Christopher you this
is the exchange up position you thought
that linear had difficulties in this
game I think it's the evaluation uh for
the sole remaining game by the way uh
Anastasia in open section the open
section the only one yeah
actually a computer likes white of
course position but maybe it's only
because white has Rook I guess an
exchange
by how much does the evaluation like
linear's position so uh let's see
whether he plays The Right Move which
seems to be Rook A7 which he did very
nice yes so now Rook D7 becomes a clear
threat clear Rook D7 double up on the
seven you don't want to see that right
so how do you defend against it if there
is a way to defend it yeah so Yasser
already showed the main idea yes like
first to make sure that Rook comes to a
fate maybe then to tie the same request
plane Rook D5 Rook F5 exactly and then
slowly bring the king towards the Knight
I really like when you don't think like
I make this move you make this move but
with ideas where you place your pieces
seven I will try to learn all my life
how to do it but but keep failing most
of the times I I want to say that that's
kind of learning yeah this conceptual
chess it's like you you make a plan a
really a big shout out to a very dear
friend
um Jeremy Selman and I I like Jeremy's
books a lot we've we've collaborated
quite a on a number of words and we both
were like very attuned to this idea not
teaching I hear you yes yes but rather
conceptualizing and we just say well
from this position from this skeletal
position what are the best pieces what
are the best squares
and then we don't look at I go here I go
there you go oh no no I'm trying to make
this trade and I'm trying to make this
and then you find the way how to make it
exactly yeah but this is this is I think
the top level of understanding right is
it fundamental you got to get this uh
the planning that you get the planning
right everything else falls into place
and it was actually really funny there
was this one story that was really great
by Larry Christensen so Larry's uh
they're waiting for the closing ceremony
at I think it was an American open and
there was this of one game to finish you
know these Swiss is the end of the
swisses everybody's tired everybody just
wants their check and to go home
and of course this one game keeps going
on and on and it's affecting all the
prizes and this one you know class a
player comes over and says I want a
brilliancy and like Larry Christensen
John grief the best players in America
Walter Brown I said they're like get out
of here the guy goes bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang
and leaves
and Larry says who who was that mass
Grandmaster and the guy had just
finished reading this book
um
the art of attack who wrote The Art of
attack Christian I forgot the the art of
attack
The Art of War no
and it's laosu so don't do that the art
of attack by I thought it was a
yugosavian grandmaster's name but okay
the point and only the fire on the board
right and fire on the ground
thank you yes art of attack and the guy
explains that vukovic had said you got
to do this and this is with you Perry
pieces and he's looking around okay I do
this I do that and do that and it's me
yes
wow and it just was perfect and it was
like the the perfect
um uh seller for uh the art of attack
that's very nice but conceptualizing
King H4 on the board
Jennifer is on fire
wow yeah that's I mean again we talk
about five hours six hours of play I
mean you know you could spoil it but she
didn't she didn't she did oh we've got
Rook check
and she came back to B6 yes right
but now that the king is on G4
now I'm in time right now once again the
most resilient way uh no you're still
not in time because F3 I go King H2
right and I get I get chased back
immediately with Rook check right and
then it's it's uh whoops this is not
okay okay so she did it right she went
back
so what do I have to do I have to pass
with
the same idea of three no that's not so
clear though is it
is this so clear because now I still
have Rook before exactly on your agenda
you don't just you just don't win right
away
in that position probably not like Rook
to B2 what do you do in that position
what here Rook C2 Rook takes B7 Rook to
B2 let's see let's see what's going to
come on the board well we have Rook C7
and by the way and this might get
important at some point Jennifer is on
seven minutes yes
12. okay yes final factor is important
always always
Rook C7 the the computer like uh the
best move in the position yes
and now I think the most resilient would
be for beg him try to go Rook to B4 Rook
to B4 stop you from playing F3 and how
do you make progress
stop F3
is it don't tell me it's a zoo and I go
Rook here and then you have to either
move your Rook or move your king
okay and what if I go Rook B6 right
exactly this is what happened she was
she's done it Rook the B4 Rook to D7
Rook back to B6 but you were saying that
you've got to stop me from playing F3
don't you
have three King H2 let's say I go King
G1 or even King G1 you can go whoa wow
still fine you're still fine leaving
after King G1 yeah because you don't
have King H3 always Rook H6 yes but now
maybe we have to give a move
I don't know it's a girl gets seven with
the idea king of one Rook H1
and if you move your Rook I don't know
guys we're having fun but I bet you the
hearts are pounding the chessboards
right now as begum despite the move Rook
before and does this require a a light
touch it requires some finesse yes so
Rook to D7 let's wait one more time Rook
to D7 and now I have to go Rook at this
point I will have to go with F3 right
now and then I go King G1 and now Rook
H7 yes this Rook H7 I thought about it
yes but so now Rook before Check Yes and
then King S5 the idea is to actually
just go no no King H3 couldn't get three
still okay
wow and then what
and then I go G4 and then I put my king
back on H4 and then I go Rook D7 I see
so okay so the ideal setup you want is
F3 G4 King H4 yes that's ooh she's
reaching for a king yes she's probably
going to go for King F5 maybe try to
transition on the other side foreign
by the way sorry the the clocks the
clock is like five already oh King H4
maybe she just repeats
okay so King H oh excuse me I'm gonna
refresh my board I apologize
uh
look this way and this way so King H4 so
Rook B6 well maybe you don't want to go
Rook B6 because now I can go G4 right
okay so let's go King H to keep the
opposition Fair
King F3 probably King H3 is a problem
that makes sense and then Rook C3 check
and things of that nature
and you get the invasion with your king
to chitsu makes a lot of sense to go yes
for King H2 probably sets up the most
problems in the position and now Rook F7
right yes
there are times that I just want to go
G4 and F3 right yes
yes I think that's uh I like that move a
lot Rick and anytime you reach for your
F Pawn then I'll go back and I'll check
and I'll come in this way that's losing
that's clear
so King H4 this is why you wanted to
play Rook B5 Christian yes Rook b5g4
though that's the problem yeah I I don't
think there is a safe any saving move no
unfortunately for begging there doesn't
seem to be a saving race at this point
let's try it out though okay so King H2
you go Rook F7 yeah okay now let's try
to go Rook B6 and try to transition to
the eighth rank you go G4 I give you a
check on H6 and then we play this
position you go King G5 I go Rook h8
okay how easy is the conversion right
now uh actually I first of all I'm not
even sure it's easy but I'm it's strange
that the first thing that came through
my mind was making a beeline towards the
P3 part yes if I could play King takes
B3 and lose my two versus one majority
but pick up this I think I'm easily
winning that absolutely so let's look at
that King F5
let's go Rook G8
group G8 keeping me honest okay I can at
least reposition my Rook where it will
instead of being passive it will
actually that's exactly that is a good
move yeah that is a very good move
important move always in these Rook
endings uh Anastasia for our viewers is
one of the things that I've I've I've
come to learn I mean and sorry that it's
so simple and repetitive active play for
your pieces whether it be for your
kingdom that's what you're trying to
find the way guys what they've just
saved it
I think that they've just saved it no
yes
Alice played rookie five Ellis didn't
find this idea with Rook H4 yes yes
E5 and now Bishop D3 the pawn marches
maybe there is still Rock history and if
you play before I take the bishop this
is hard
yes
oh my God this is actually an easy draw
right now oh
right and by the way rookie 5 might
actually be the only move that makes it
wrong really why like every other thing
maybe not King B6 yeah the go away
towards right towards the Oblivion The
Rook H4 was was nice just because case
three Rook H4 Rook G5 look at five
Bishop bishop and now there's no
stopping because anywhere else you would
play Rook to the fourth Rank and stuff
oh yes maybe oh wow wow that's that's
painful yeah wow and this is her third
time that she's doing this she did that
against Irina yes remember she had this
chance to win yesterday against uh two
days ago with the Bishops I used that
against the junior as I said okay said I
said to Rochelle okay so show me the win
and she goes why do I have to show you
the win I said because they told me
you're a genius she said that they
what was it are you sure they were
talking about me
[Laughter]
that she saw that she's losing she saw
the variation yes yes so but she said
already I had no choice at this moment
but and of course you didn't find this
year her opponent didn't find it yes the
rookie sometimes you can see in the
Europe and again exactly we say it once
more I mean Alice played great I mean
for five six hours if she just played
Rook H4 played Rook F4
Pawn is Frozen the bishop is frozen and
eventually H4
is going to cost us at the bishop
that hurts back to our uh open yes one
other way of winning the position which
is very very important uh Christopher
cannot afford to trade Rooks yes yes
this is what I wanted just to ask you
yesterday can I exchange one Rook I mean
is it going to be completely winning
completely winning because then the king
just simply goes to watch History
yeah but it's that presence with the
Rook you always have things where you
could be checkmating me and somehow the
night is doing it but uh definitely
Lanier is looking to trade a pair of
Rooks
and then his king would March
triumphantly into the position and again
I'm going to jump back to Jennifer that
would be a heartbreak for Alice
after King H4 do we have moves between
um no no
it looks like yes wow
the question is also in linear position
how to trade those Rooks I mean like if
you play rookie 6 Knight D6 I mean maybe
you have to put your roots yes shall I
go back to the game between Lanier and
Christopher yes so for example like if
you try to trade the Rooks on Knight H3
okay inviting the trade King G3 Knight
F4 Knight F4 okay okay 696 obviously yes
yes and then like then you're stuck
though right so now your rook and Knight
can't move anytime your night moves I
trade The Rook exactly but I yes now
that's zucked one because this is what
he was playing before right let's say so
Knight cannot move Rook cannot move so
only the king can move exactly so what
we do here rookie four now yes the king
moves okay so so great I've kind of well
not quite maximized but now what I'm
going to do as soon as you put your king
there now it's going to be very hard for
you to play Rook at four yes I'll
sacrifice mine
takes a four years exactly nice okay
this is really nice so Rooker 4 is not
possible and you will need to keep your
Rook on yes this is beautiful
and everything goes to a four so you
need what to keep your Rook or King on
G6 let's say yeah but now I'm I'm trying
to think how do we make my triumphant uh
King march uh it's not it's not not at
that I tried to think the way you taught
me Yasser so maybe I have to move my
Rook A6 A5 and Rook F5 if I if it's
possible to trade the Rooks this way yes
okay time on time so okay that makes a
lot of sense so after nope nope pardon
me after King G6 yeah but we're gonna go
Rook here you're gonna go King back I'm
gonna go Rook here five and then then
maybe you try to escape with Rook F4
then I go Rook F5 no and then I go with
G5 and yeah our yes of course yeah
and if you go King here then I try
rookie five yes and you cannot even take
it because it's G takes a five and I get
it yes and you trade them
let's go back to Jennifer because that
is the influential one that we have
right now and three minutes and 30
seconds only for Jenny for six minutes
for backing she needs to find a way to
break through right now by the way after
uh Knight F4 we do have okay six Lanier
says let's trade The Rook uh Christopher
uh but do we have any moves if the king
H2 no so King H2 was playing King H2 was
played
it's just probably oh my God so
heartbroken at this exact moment
oh and she's covering her yeah this is
heartbreaking yeah she's like oh Alice
you could have done this and Alice is
like oh I should have done that yeah
yeah oh no oh no
lost probably this is what and if it
would happen in one game it would be one
thing but it's been happening in the
last three games and it's these endings
where she's been failing she's been
playing brilliant chess to get to these
winning positions winning position
against Irena against Anna against very
experienced players and then she just
doesn't convert at the critical moment
yes but but okay let's say this is the
easy part to let's say to improve right
the winning positions essentially I
learned how to win them yeah so she will
study a little bit more maybe it will
get some experience I think it comes
also with time you know simply with time
and then she'll be she will turn to
really great player I think like no
question is really really good really
and by the way after the move rugby we
do have King H2 she didn't go for uh
pardon me um Jennifer did not go for
that Rook F7
King
G2 G4 position
waiting yes and I'm not expecting I
would assume King to G2 okay another
waiting move right she's a bit torturing
also beg him and trying to make her life
hard you know time is is actually
running exactly so it's going to be more
difficult to defend this position with
small minutes for example yes a very
practical like the repeat position a
little bit here a little bit there she
has this chance to wait yeah was that
something by the way we spoke about it
did was that something that you were
taught in let's say this Ukrainian
School of Chess that you should re
repeat the position once whether it's
game time or just to show to your
opponent
I'm the one who is actually yes that's
an interesting actually a question
that's even psychological once again
there are a few things like you what you
achieve by repeating the position first
of all you move towards the time control
right first so especially especially
people like me who like to think uh you
know you better move it get closer to
get closer to time control so let's say
this is the first thing and secondly yes
you kind of repeat and you show to your
opponent that I'm thinking to make a
draw with you or not to make and then
you avoid and it's maybe some extra
pressure on your opponent sometimes but
I was not good on this yes not so much
but actually what made me laugh a little
bit the other day that Fabiano caruana
said that it was Christopher you when he
played this position and you remember at
the very end Christopher kept this apone
and he was playing until the stale made
so Fabi was turned towards the stalemate
and for some time he played with the
Rooks on the board but then he saw the
kid under 50 moves you know to play with
Rooks and so it's also like you know you
don't want to be in the position of the
person who will get to stay a little bit
right sometimes so you try to avoid it
is it important no for me no but maybe
for all the players it's important let's
say who who was making the draw Victor
korchstone it was furious with Anatoly
carpa from a Baguio city world
championship match they had a dead draw
and uh he was put into stalemate for
example yes and he was Furious yes no
respect no exactly
and there you could offer a drawer right
at that time you could offer a door at
least here it's understandable like you
kind of look for the position where it's
either three times repetition or
stalemate let's say but I mean I can't
imagine why he was nervous if in America
would be too exactly exactly let me just
refresh my board and catch up between uh
begum and Jennifer and those moves have
been playing no moves that was the last
move yes all right no move split what
about time
eventually they're going to be down to
their increments yes one minute and 50
seconds I believe for begging maybe we
can see the full three minutes for
Jennifer she must feel like she's got
all the time in the world at the moment
yes three and a half to make a move
because that's exactly what Jennifer
wants yeah she wants her too and she's
reaching for the Rook which is kind of a
surprise B6 so she's inviting Jennifer
to play G4
G4 is correct G4 is is the dream is the
big dream that you had for the last many
many moves right exactly
so uh Jennifer could now play
the setup that she wants G4 with the
idea of Rook F2 and with the threat of
Rook F2 it will be a two versus one you
can take this but it'll cost you your F2
Pawn so where's this idea perhaps is to
try to go after G4 Rook F6 is that it
okay
to take this Pawn
take that pawn but now King to G5 and
Rook on the third Rank and just win that
pawn seems decisive that's a simple but
the other one or F3 yeah F3 even though
then my king goes to G3
I'm not sure it does
not yeah yes because yeah
I mean you can you can check me but uh
well wait a minute I shouldn't allow
this I beg your pardon no no that's not
it is
yeah that seems to be still winning
wow what a tough tough tough
in game and what yeah well G4 I mean
what else
uh for Jennifer to play here well she
definitely must be thinking about it
because she's been trying to make G4
work for a very long time absolutely
yeah G4 is like main line
yes yes exactly and that was the whole
purpose of just like wasting time and
waiting around 77 looking seven back and
forth
I'm spending lots of time right now I
think they will literally play soon with
increment only only yes like and she's
reaching for her Rook maybe okay first
right there's some hovering going on the
hovering okay but rooted to for example
that looks like a very good move too
because Rook D2 King King now G4 and I
still I have the same ideas of F3 check
as well as G3 for that matter don't
forget that G3 could also appear on the
board yes she plays
probably a must how about King G1 just
to try to oh kg2 came very very quickly
so G4 yes and now Jennifer she's got the
Mojo going this is it the the King Pawn
the the pawns are coming through
decisively
F3 check on her agenda
yeah it's not even visually you can see
that the black like oh yeah I mean I
mean
with this move G3 purposely traded a
Jeep on for an H Pawn yes which usually
in these situations is a No-No because
you you end up
um well exactly in a situation like this
this is how you could lose it but
actually you know yes it's always
controversial like we know that if
you're on the weak side of this but you
don't have material you try to trade
your pawns right so it's just always so
difficult to remember which rule applies
at this moment and actually which one is
not working at all because we know that
in chess we have rules and exceptions
yeah maybe sometimes it's more than the
exceptions May or more often than the
rules right yes so it's Yeah It's Tricky
yeah
those says the position sometimes
now she has to fight against two ideas
GCV and F3 and it's really hard like
probably she's thinking about like Rook
H6 move but then King G5 and G3 and then
yeah G3 is the next one uh Anastasia
question for you on behalf of our
audience because I think that
um chess coaches uh of all of the chess
coaches that you worked with in the
Ukraine and Olympic teams and uh with
your colleagues and you talk about them
who were some of the best
chess coaches for women's teams that
that you said they understand no
actually I must mention this that we
have a very good coach coach for
Ukrainian women's team Mikhail Brodsky
he's a brand master of 650 level let's
say his understanding of course maybe
even better because he doesn't play that
often anymore but and also Alexander
kovjan also helps there are two coaches
two let's say really good Grandmasters
of 600 plus level right and I must say
that they do a really great job as you
could remember that the Ukrainian team
won the Olympiad right now a huge upset
thank you America yes yes okay
we thank you for helping us understand
too right yes with Ukraine so I must say
this but so he's really doing really
great job and I know how hard he's
working and he really prepares all girls
and also he has a very good approach
psychological also approaching I don't
know what he what he's what how he finds
all these words you know but he really
finds them I mean he's done a really
great job very very nice to hear uh by
the way after G4 Rook takes
G3 very nice taking it now that the pawn
on F2 is pinned all Jennifer has to do
is but Rook takes F2 check and she's got
the game
check
King G5 and it looks terrible begum
can't do anything at the moment she can
run with her Pawn up the board B4 but it
doesn't get far Rook takes check and The
Rook comes right behind the pawn and
that's ideal that's that's absolutely
ideal for Jennifer the The Rook there's
another role
six yes so she's just nicely done
walking towards the Rook no more checks
Rook takes F2 is next and then Rook to
B2 and who knows maybe even this King
can even especially if the King goes
back to G1 yeah right we're going to see
that King march to F3 exactly that's
what I was thinking as well
some sort of a
cocoon on F3 yes
so white has to spend time also for
playing Rook G8 yes which is just what
happened probably take this pawn and
also yep perhaps at this point your only
chance to try for something is to go
King H3
and
hope for the best hope for the best hope
for some Rook H2 King G4 and
so maybe you get some chances some dirty
but of course after King H3 King F5 and
once again
threatening marches towards F3 and
that's a problem yeah also there's a
checkmate
that hurts King G1 on the board yes and
for Jennifer I mean holy smokes her
score
uh will be eight out of ten ten yeah you
were saying that in the the championship
that Jennifer won was 10 out of 11 yes
at that time right wow but uh still I
mean maybe it's gonna be enough out of
11 this time she keeps winning like that
ah yeah that's uh
that's amazing no sorry it will be eight
out of 11 now but we have still two
games to go yes and and and who were
those
um terrific Grand Masters
who predicted her Victory
[Laughter]
tomorrow
and by the way I really like her
attitude like you are the one who makes
your faith you know no one else can help
you if you have problems with the
opponent you are the one to solve them
right right I liked it very much very
very much no I I must say she impressed
me as all with uh okay so I can see one
trick in the position for example you
take on B4 that's the truth and then now
I go King G2 okay now you give me
another Chuck that's what I would do and
now I go King F3 King F3 okay and then I
give you another a check now I go King
E4 King E4 and then I go G2 now I stay
now I just go then I go F3 then it's
over
you were so eloquent you're trying to
find something in that position
it was like really impressed
there's nothing it's really yeah
not before this moment it's over yeah
yeah there's no Escape at this point
it's really you don't need the king
they move by itself though yes exactly
it's the cat's leather yes exactly
okay so Ruby two
um
[Music]
wow
that's that was a good fight
first for the photo places let's say yes
in King F3 I think we're marching in
that exact Direction I mean the coaches
yeah yeah yeah through us as Moses uh
telling uh how how to win this game by
the way there were it only occurred to
me much much later
yes but the audience had asked I had
gotten angry at a game and I said yeah
there was this one time yes very popular
by the way everybody should check it but
I realized
much more recent example and I was
Furious about it again again what
happened
so there's an Unwritten code of conduct
Unwritten code of conduct amongst chess
commentators yeah
and the unwritten code of conduct
basically goes like this
the commentators are trying to make our
participants Heroes you know like we we
praise them to the sky as we cry with
them when they make them mistakes the
commentators should not beat up
the players during the competition and
during the candidates in Madrid Dania
Daniel narodetsky
yes during the competition and it raises
questions and doubts in the audience
mind like why is Dania not playing if
he's beating up I'll erase it and
equally I was furious with Judith pogar
Judith Polgar official commentator the
shame on her free day walks through the
park and decides to play Magnus Carlson
and destroys him in a Blitz game now was
she thinking about her audience the next
day like saving her secrets for the
audience no she was just selfishly
beating up on the world champion so
these two players now I've talked to
dania about it and he understands me and
he because why
because a month later there was the
senior championships going on here in St
Louis I have never felt so vulnerable
the people at home were saying yes sir
why aren't you playing
you see how it works I mean
yes it was time
so Unwritten code of conduct okay the
point is you don't go on the free day
and beat up on the women
competitors in the field
after only after you can do the
tournament it's or if you want to play
then you should be ready to lose all the
games yes something like that okay
and we do have G2 on the board we have
King H3 and as you were just saying the
pawns you don't even need the king
absolutely the Pawns in the roof on the
board is all that's necessary
so you could feel my wrath yes I
understand yes my upset yes yes
especially to F1 followed by H1 with a
king on H2 exactly of course again the
same thing what you said is absolutely
correct yes sir I mean even though begem
didn't manage to hold this position she
tried her best in this game let's say
she was fighting until the very end and
let's say she's looking for some chances
and of course I mean it's not easy after
so many games so many rounds still keep
your energy at the same level it's all
about the energy we've seen similar
blunders in uh Darius verch versus Sam
Seville exactly exactly yes
yeah they happen look this is the 11th
round by the way did I get that right
one second one second on the clock yes
yes and it was sort of like okay no yeah
but because she understands the position
is lost
it doesn't matter anymore right yes
she's trying to set up some clever
stalemate okay so I see The Rook F5
right
um
right now that is cute this is nice so
go ahead please promote your Pawn look
at this no promotion
this is cool actually it's beautiful I
mean yes it deserves a better fate yes
uh such a it's a beautiful trap do you
want a rook
oh
the torture you're about Jennifer played
Rook F1 and now you're reminding me of
these nature films I see where the orcas
are playing with their prey they don't
just eat the seal right away
but after this result uh tell us about
the women's final standings Anastasia so
Jennifer you kept your first place I
mean eight
um
eleven I mean great job Jennifer by
winning this game arena crashes is on
the second place Half Upon behind and
then we have Thalia Cervantes on Korea
third place with seven points look at
this clear four wins in a row but
honestly she's still there should have
been there at seven but she's still in
the it's still in the mix as you see
Jennifer you
getting wanted uh she leaves
wow uh huge results that leaves us with
one game
yes you're actually going straight into
the line that you guys were mentioning
oh still I thought they will do it half
an hour ago
they still have four minutes and 13
minutes respectively so this one is
a professional he knows that it's a
step-by-step process and actually this
is the exact idea you showed them two
hours ago yesterday like you have to
bring all your pieces too and and you
freeze black the freezes rip you freeze
his night and you freeze his King so uh
let's say you go here the king cannot go
here because the Rook relax protection
nice right and
The Rook can't move because of the pond
the Knight can't move because of the
pond so the King has to go back and now
you start thinking about uh
can you I know
probably King upon end games right now
or too soon but you you first March your
King well he played the other way he
played King G2
what
okay sorry I'm gonna have to refresh my
board I apologize
he played King G2
which is a bit weird where are you going
I really don't know
it's a bit weird are you trying to
triangulate that I mean whether you're
doing the king F1 King F2 is that uh
where are you going linear yeah I think
he's just kind of I was thinking rookie
seven was an automatic jokes
help me understand this move Christian
come on Coach I apologize yes I do not
have an answer for this one I I don't
know what the king is doing on G2 I
would assume he's just trying to win
some time and confuse his opponent I
think yes it's just like some kind of
like it's all about confusion you know
dialogue I can even play King just don't
still win this position you know go King
H1 make fun of your opponents things of
that English one I like it just visit a
lot of very random schools yes
um
around the Mary version okay of course
yeah
because seventh then King 57 right look
at this no G3 okay of course
triangulation this is really no
distance
I've never seen this one and uh we have
a guest uh in studio with your Christian
we are indeed with the leader in the
ladies section Jennifer you after
another crucial Victory Jennifer
congratulations a big one with the black
pieces against one of your main
competitors how do you feel right now
um yeah I mean I'm pretty happy with the
result uh going to this game like I
didn't really know what to play against
her
um played the Pet Shop so it's kind of
drawish for a while but you know I was
also like I really wanted to win this
game like it was a strange decision
because I was trying to just get like a
playable position so that I could win
but
um I mean I guess it ended up working
out but did you feel uh that you
surprised her with this Petrov decision
I think I did
um because she's thought for a while
here before playing D4 but
um I I thought like she was gonna expect
it because I have played this quite a
few times in the past but
um I have been playing really random
openings this tournament so it probably
makes it harder Bishop D3 D5 and you
entered this main line with the bishop
on D6 and she decided to go for Knight
C3 instead of C4
did you know anything about the position
were you still in your book at this
point
uh no I
for some reason 1967 just completely
like I was like oh it did not expect
1967. it's already here Knight takes
yeah even though it's like definitely
very popular
um because I I thought she was gonna
play like
um I think she was in a castle or
something but uh I mean I knew a little
bit about this position because I played
this for a few years so I know it's like
some ideas but um so I wasn't like
afraid of going into this and she took
on D7 and I think this was quite
critical at this point F5 C4 how did you
assess the position right now I think
you spent quite a long time uh playing
this move Queen to F6 yeah
um my time usage here was not that great
um but I just could not decide because
there was a few ideas I could do here
um I could also take on C4 and canadi I
just didn't like that as much I think
I don't know what the valuation was I
think it should be okay yeah I thought
it was like around that quality yeah
yeah but I just thought this was
um less of a practical chance because
thing is I know I'm black but I you know
I don't like drawing I like I like doing
so
um I thought like that would just be
more passive positions so I thought
Queen F6 was just like a better chance
um because here okay so I assume she was
also trying to beat me which is also
like why I did this open because
otherwise I think like if you want you
could play Bishop G5
um trade the Queens off and then it
should be like a pretty simple like
um end game this one yeah and then you
can move the bishop back and yeah so I I
mean I don't know
it's you can definitely play on for a
while but I think it's like a very
simple compared to the game so that's
why um I was like really happy see
Bishop D3 which I kind of expected to
because it also like complicates the
position more
um and this move came on board
H4 no I was like H4 at first I was like
what is this
um because it seems so impractical
because like now your Queen's stuck on
H5 but Bishop G5 is actually kind of a
problem
um in a lot of moves so I was like oh
this move H4 I can't believe it works
but does
so you play Bishop D5 Bishop P3 C6
and finally she got her Bishop G5
at the only moment that she could have I
think this was another critical moment
it felt like she was getting closer and
closer to making a draw
but then you ladies got into this end
game how did you assess this one at this
point I mean I thought this was should
be a draw but
um it's I don't know like what is the
correct is it just F3 Rook B4 I think
King G1 was fine okay and go all the way
to here and now just G3 was it feels
like a bad mistake yeah that's the thing
like here I was like already accepting
this might be a draw but the thing is
she still has to defend it um and that's
like it's really tricky here because it
looks like G3 should be easily drawn but
like it just I get there's like six one
at some point like not like six one it's
just kind of like what happened in the
game where it's like and I think this
was the critical move you found this
move King to H4
because if you go F3 first and King G3
if you go G4 first then Rook to B4 seems
to equalize the position yeah um King to
H4 and
at this point you guys were repeating
moves and then she allowed you to go G4
what were was your plan after King to G2
um work T3 Rook D3
because then if she takes now you go F3
it's like transposes to like um because
before she could have taken on b72 would
have been the same thing but she played
um at what point uh
yeah right here when I play Teenage four
it's the same thing
got it yeah but you can take but now you
go F3 yeah so Rook B4 was knife moved by
her but
um now Rook before doesn't work because
because
I got like confused it I was like it
looks like something weird is not going
on
so I think at this point
oh never mind
so Rook to D7 King to G2 was the
question but now you go to D3 yeah and
then yeah and then now your rook's still
stuck on B4 and if you go King H2 oh now
you can go here right and then King H3
was that it
no this is one
how are you planning on making progress
oh here I think I was just gonna go like
I could oh maybe this and this and just
wait yeah I think that no no now you can
take on B7 the problem is the King has
to be on H4
um I think uh Teenage two I was gonna do
oh I could do G4 right
King H2 oh no no G4 is not good they're
gonna
maybe B5 here yeah wait B5 not B6
but no this is because you the pollen
has to be on F3
where's the wind guys so you're doing a
great job Christian We're Not Gonna
I looked at this for sure
um
it says 57 King H2 let's try to figure
out maybe Rook to F7 here
and now King to G4
yeah you cannot wait anymore yeah so she
has to do something you have to go here
and now we have three
there we go we found it anyway very nice
conversion after that she did not play
this uh important victory for you you're
going into tomorrow's match against
Irina crush with a half point lead how
are you going to approach that one
well I think I'm gonna just kind of
approach it normally the thing is I I
always think I was kind of joking around
a few days ago and I was like I really
like playing like must win kind of
situations because I always have a lot
of fun playing those I don't know I just
like to play Under Pressure so I was
like maybe I should just treat every
single game like that yeah must win the
situation
um I mean obviously you know if I don't
have to go crazy if it's like very drawn
but I think you know I'm gonna just play
normally like in that way
um yeah this is also I think the last
time I played this tournament I also had
the same situation I was like half Point
late second to last round so hopefully
we have the same result but we'll see
guys any questions congratulations
you're playing playing great somehow you
do well matching up with Arena I was
really surprised in your head to head
you have two wins in one row what is it
about your games in the past with Arena
that's benefited you
um
I think back on the last few times we
played
um
are maybe it was it's because of our
Styles but um I think I'm also always
black every single time we play like I
think every single time so this will be
interesting
um because I don't maybe I played her
once this way or something like that
tomorrow you're going to be black again
I'm black again I think tomorrow
wait wait wait wait wait don't mess her
up she's she's doing great without your
help
our producer is trying to yeah
so but
um
so I think I've always kind of played
the game on like her terms a little bit
because she's kind of like choosing kind
of positions we're heading to so it'd be
interesting to see what I do with weight
all right well we'll be watching yes the
whole world will be watching actually uh
nice good luck Jim
great job and we have a one game
remaining uh two this oh pardon me three
decisive results so far in the open
Lanier is trying to make it four
decisive results he's just played the
move Rook D2 once again he's hunting
down this Rook he's trying to play Rook
here and yeah once again just changing
one pair of Rooks okay it's
I mean he's he hasn't spoiled anything
it's just he's just definitely taken a
lot of time to get here and
Christopher's been doing everything he
can uh he kept his night active uh did
everything he could to avoid a rook
trade and he's got an active King as
well so
57. will follow the questions
I don't know I'll be a little bit more
active so maybe on a good day I want to
go like King Eve well if I could do it I
have just want to double on the seventh
rank so if you don't mind I'll just play
a bad move for you just no it's not a
bad move but a series of bad moves a
sequence if you will of bad moves
unfortunately there was rookie one but
yeah exactly well you're going to get
your check I'll give you so this is
where you could really mess things up
for yourself because now yes I've got
the thread of meat and two now you don't
have to give me that second check but if
you go back with the night
then eventually oops excuse me I'm about
to play rookie seven and then I will
force a trade of Rooks but it's it's
been a very very very slow method of
towards Victory but I don't think he's
oh
Christopher you hover this is because
I think I think this is the move that
you made also yes and you say it's a
version
yes you said it's like let's make some
bad moves
did I make a bad move
um so what if you do the same thing
let's say Rook B7 right right or okay
seven yes
you know it's funny I I I played blitz
so often in my life that I keep my Rooks
as far away from the night as I possibly
can so that I don't walk into a fork but
Rook A7 would probably be my the one
thing I would I would stop to think
about is could I may I just take a look
at this one like where do you go
so so if you go to seven shrink again I
go play Rook G7 yes and actually you
cannot play Rook H2 now because it's a
it really is
Kebab
exactly I mean Greek Souvlaki Souvlaki
we've got Souvlaki yeah okay so rook d8
and I think it's time so you have to go
to H1 H1 okay might be the only movie
that exactly and if I'm trying to set up
those same kind of mates let's start
giving some checks
check okay
let's give another one okay
let's go rookie three okay three and
let's see if I can't this one Chuck can
you get the Checkmate oh huh okay so
I'll take that and then is there any
defense and that's a good question yes
now
because yeah obviously I do have this
threat of so 90s five maybe sorry 96 96
um
look at this so you just
saved yourself
maybe even we'll take a Pawn on G4 and
don't get greedy apologies apologies I
was trying to be too clever
but he has to go to kitchen right now
what is he thinking about okay and he's
done it okay Juan is here and maybe
after oh sorry
and he's played Rook H1 correct yes so
I'll play Rook D1
uh first you try to get rid of the room
okay but now I go okay
[Laughter]
what do I do against Rook H2 Rook D2 no
they don't make any any process so I
apologize I guess Rook D1 is not so
clever it's still not easy right right
still not easy Christopher is holding on
or dear life okay let's go to that
position
with the idea to bring the king yes the
second rule goes to date was the idea
maybe to move the king through E4 to F5
for example Jade
wow Rook G8
uh sorry to say guys but I think that we
have to wrap things up uh our production
but very very exciting action for
tomorrow's round as our number one
Jennifer you plays number two Arena
Crush exactly maybe for all the marbles
she could be finishing the tournament
tomorrow if she wins yeah exactly that's
the white pieces exactly Jennifer
and Bobby on the other on the open
section he still leads but things have
gotten a little bit tighter thanks to
Savion and what we think Lanier
Dominguez Victory will mean as well as
Ray Robson keeps a slim half point for
the second plate Christian sum up
today's action with some final thoughts
what around then we're finally starting
uh to see how important those energy
levels are because we've seen some
unusual blunders I'm thinking about that
Darius uh blunder Baggins blunder with a
G3 so the energy levels are extremely
important right now and tomorrow they're
going to be crucial because we have some
battles between Generations especially
that one that big match between Jennifer
you and Irina Crush we're going to have
our eyes glued to the screen and we will
be calling all the action here in the
studio absolutely thank you for that
Christian Anastasia another great day
thank you thank you yes sir
and tomorrow it's going to be even
better thank you everyone tomorrow for
joining us and we're going to say good
night see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited